an arrest has been made
in the
case of a man who threw a molotov
cocktail into the headquarters for the
democratic party in austin apparently
the device didn't go off but it's just
another example of how insane things are
getting and maybe people would say tim
it's just one incident it's not
indicative of anything but i do think
it's another grain of sand and heap you
see stories like this they travel far
and wide they they perpetuate on the
internet and it may be just one incident
but certainly people on the left will
see it and say see look the far right
are extremists the right will say dude
that guy's crazy and nobody supports
that it must be a fed or something like
that it doesn't matter people will use
it it will drive sentiment and that's
what keeps happening because the
internet
it's really riling people up it's it's
it's making everybody a bit
hyper partisan i mean it's really
driving the extremes
but outside of this it's just another
sign that i believe we are in some kind
of downward trajectory we have a
personal finance expert who is
predicting the biggest economic crash in
history or something that affect this
month
so certainly these things are a bit
alarming and
i don't know maybe a bit pessimistic but
we do have other things to talk about
because in that pessimism there are
interesting things and joining us today
is the writer and host of the new hit
show from tim cast
shane cashman of tales from the inverted
world thanks for having me yeah you want
to briefly introduce yourself yeah i'm
shane cashman i'm uh writing tales from
the inverted world been going down
rabbit holes every week for you guys
talking about aliens and people getting
abducted and murdered ghosts murders um
we'll do some cryptids soon yeah some of
it's like legit investigative reporting
though you know like tracking down
confederate gold you know whatever yeah
yeah that pans out i'll hit up people
and i'll next thing i know i'm
in some weird town talking to some
people about their alien abduction so
the show is officially up on spotify i
think it's it's slowly rolling on all
the podcast platforms it takes time it's
on youtube the link to the channel is in
the description below and it's like a
fully produced i think we're looking at
like what 12 to 20 minutes per episode
the third episode might be 40. 40
minutes because it's like a full true
crazy true crime 1970s hell's kitchen
new york city awesome yeah but one of
the last uh latest things you've written
is about the rat utopia experiment and
breaking all that down and so as we're
talking about collapse you know before
the show we were talking about like
snapchat filters instagram like weird
performances and the way people dress
the beautiful ones
like these these these there were mice
or rats in this particular one so john b
calhoun started with rats and uh he
built what he called these universes of
rats and he wanted to populate them with
uh he would put in like four males four
females
and they would just like every 55 days
would just like grow exponentially
at first though they wouldn't use up all
the space they would like but they would
overcrowd in the way that they would
find each other and just start like
lumping together but the beautiful ones
specifically were like they would just
groom themselves and groom themselves
that would go on if once the population
grew and the space was the only thing
that they didn't have any like they had
no more space
the beautiful ones would emerge and
they're these people are mice i kind of
feel like we're experiencing that and
that's just like when we're talking
about political chaos we're talking
about you know economic collapse or this
this story about how trump voters and
biden voters both want to secede and
then you see these videos and these
filters and it's like are we really in
this so we'll we'll get into all that
and we'll talk about the show we've got
a bunch of other crazy stories a
lockheed martin ufo has been spotted on
camera five fireballs sitting through
the sky ian was already going off about
magnetic fields well i brought my
fluorite up which is a type of crystal
if we want to get into the vibration as
your bones are made of hydroxide
all right
so this is the first i've heard that it
was four male and four female rats which
makes me wonder if it has something to
do with the inbreeding that drove them
insane
but they had more than enough genetic
diversity we had mice growing up and and
that one of the mothers had sex with one
of the babies and then had a baby that
was all deformed and had like a lung
problem and it died a couple
weeks after so that gives me some hope
that maybe we're not the rats in the
cage because we're not inbred well we'll
we'll we will we will uh sort through
all this stuff we got lydia pressing all
the buttons i am excited to sort through
all this stuff this evening i'm really
excited for this new show it sounds
amazing you guys should go on over and
check it out thank you the new studio is
done yes
it's uh uh but we have to
clean it yep so it's like we're we're
ready to set up everything okay i should
say the construction is done now it's
just a few hours of positioning the
cameras and everything which is not that
hard to do like a half day but we have
to wait until they steam clean
everything because
construction just ended so it's like
it's not completely done but um maybe
monday maybe it depends what happens but
it's probably going to be tuesday or
wednesday in the new studio the lighting
is crazy awesome it's going to look
really really great if you've watched
the vlog you would have seen it but
let's get into the news before we do
head over to timcast.com become a member
and you'll get exclusive access to
segments from this show we put them up
monday through thursday but also
now with the launch of tales from the
inverted world there's going to be a
members only podcast discussion about
the episode exploring these issues and
we're going to be having guests as well
you know many of the people you probably
have already seen on this show we're
really hoping alex jones would want to
come in and and talk about conspiracies
with shane you know so uh when shane
writes one of these stories there'll be
a follow-up kind of like talking about
asking questions exploring things in
depth that'll be available soon as well
and we're also launching another show
called the green room which is our green
room hanging out with the guests before
the show so that's what you get as a
member but don't forget to like this
video subscribe to this channel and
don't forget in the description below
is the youtube channel for tales from
the inverted world and you can check out
episode one it's 12 minutes and 31
seconds it's awesome there's sound
effects it's creepy and there's a
general introduction to the show and to
shane's work and uh we're still building
everything out as i always say you just
start now this is a fully produced show
with with you know research writing
independent investigation and sound
effects and original music made by
carter here in the house so it takes a
lot of work to get to that point and
then we put it up and now the goal is
over time we're gonna start building it
up it's gonna get better the art is
absolutely amazing jessica did like some
of the best art i've ever seen i'm so
excited for this so in the description
you will see the link subscribe to that
channel
and we'll we'll get into some of these
topics but we're gonna start with the
real world and in the real world crazy
stuff is happening we have the story
from cbs austin
arrest made an arson incident at travis
county democratic party office they say
a molotov cocktail was thrown inside the
office and ignited during the early
morning of early early morning hours so
earlier i was wrong i thought it didn't
but it did the arson suspect was
recorded on security cameras and a note
was left at the scene the austin fire
department says their arson
investigators along with the fbi made
the arrest ryan faircloth 30 is charged
with second-degree felony arson and
third degree felony possession of a
prohibited weapon he remains in custody
at travis county jail under a combined
40 000 bond for both charges early
wednesday morning outside an outside
camera recording a man throwing a rock
through the front door of the democratic
party office he then came back with what
appears to be an incendiary device
placed it inside the building and then
uh the fire ignited damage to the
building was minimized because people at
the bar across the street spotted the
first flames and put them out with a
fire extinguisher last year vandals hit
the same building spraying graffiti
across the front that's when security
cameras were installed that may help
police find who was responsible for the
latest damage
we were talking about the other day
you know related to this what happens if
texas secedes or new hampshire and one
of the things i was saying that you know
i guess people hadn't considered is what
do the democrats in austin do if the
republicans in texas say we're out right
you can already see there's conflict
between
cultural factions that's how new york is
i mean most of new york voted red a lot
of new york
and the city controls most of it so it's
like when you talk about secession what
does something like new york city do you
were there right you lived in new york
city yeah i was driving a box truck for
uh not the riots but like leading up to
the to the 2016 election so i would see
like um all the signs for hillary in one
place and all the trump signs and the
rest of you know upstate new york
not that that should be a gauge of how
people are going to vote but it was wild
to see that yeah all of upstate new york
is one way it's so weird
but maybe it's because people in the
cities are scared they're scared to say
anything country versus city true if you
put up a trump sign in an area where
there's 50 hillary
hillary i
thanks chris
yeah that it's i mean maybe dangerous
isn't the word but maybe it is and
that's the problem with it that's why we
have secret voting you know that's why
you you're voting is anonymous yes
i wonder so we we we did talk about
taxes and for those that don't
understand the uh know the context of
the last episode you know we had we had
someone from the freestate project in
new hampshire new hampshire there's a
lot of people in new hampshire who want
to secede or form their own you know
nation state or whatever and like a lot
a lot of people say things you know if
texas can't it won't happen
but there's also the conversation we've
had where it's like the federal
government wouldn't do anything so look
at california california says outright
we no longer will allow the feds to
enforce immigration law actually
stopping them and that's a state saying
the federal government has no authority
here in this regard and the feds say
okay that's it the emperor's got no
clothes the moment california was able
to say this the moment cities in
california were allowed to were allowed
to let non-citizens vote the federal
government lost legitimacy because they
couldn't enforce their own laws within
the country
that's going to set up a cascade effect
but the interesting thing is what
happens in a state like texas if texas
succeeds the belief is the fats won't do
anything but what happens when the
democrats in austin call for help the
feds then nationalize the national guard
in neighboring states and send them into
texas to protect you know the law and
law and order
that being said that's the context
here's the next question if that does
happen and the government does
nationalize or federalize the national
guard
from new york for instance
what will the majority of the new york
state republicans in all like northern
part
say to the city you know because they're
the people who are in the national guard
in that place probably come from some
rural areas from the city from all over
and a lot of them are going to be rural
and now working at the best of i think
we could just see like conflict chaos
politically
they don't have much power the red the
red part of new york and it's almost
like new york city has already seceded
from the rest of the state because
they've locked out not to say that
everyone who's red
has not been vaccinated but if you're
not vaccinated you're not allowed in
that city anymore you can't do anything
i have a friend who went to eight
different bars in the past two days
turned away wow all of them went to her
favorite cafe told i will serve you if
you sit out outside yeah out there
that's what they said when i called so
they've locked out everybody else i i
don't know how much political swear they
have i don't even know if they care
about the city they act like it's not
there that's a good point we didn't even
talk about new york city has basically
already said yeah these people are not
welcome here
and that's a large portion i think half
of republicans are not vaccinated yeah
that means like
straight up
trump supporters the staunch supporters
of trump are completely cut off from new
york city and los angeles and new
orleans and san francisco all of these
cities that are rolling this out no zoos
this is a secession there's no
restaurants yeah they've they've
manufactured it in a way where it's not
you don't have to say secession
the weird part is like back in the day
you'd have a city block would secede
from another city block it'd be
territory but now it's kind of ideology
like
too many people live close together that
have different ideologies so you can't
you know like you said the big city
in texas is democrat but all the
surrounding areas is republican so i
think rather than a secession which
would be like shattering a crystal
crystalline form structure you would
have to somehow alter the way they
interact which this these covert
restrictions seem to be doing yeah and i
should also say that there's a lot of
people in new york city who are also
either vaccinated and against the
mandates or not vaccinated doesn't mean
they're red or blue but they're fighting
like i know people who are working in
sanitation who are fighting really hard
to keep their jobs you know this is
interesting we didn't even consider this
when having these conversations about
secession that there could be people
whose secret intention is the breakup of
the us and they do it through laws they
know are partisan that will result in a
soft secession meaning new york city has
basically said maga not welcome yeah
i've been listening to alex alex jones
did uh he was on sydney and elijah's
show and then he went on
uh gosh where did he go router yeah he
went on crowder and they were i watched
a little bit of that and i was
fact-checking what he was talking about
and klaus schwab really i mean since
for decades he's been intending to make
like a corporate global organization
governments aren't effective enough we
need corporations to work with
governments to govern the world now
pretty sure that's like mussolini's
fascism definitely it's fascism when you
when you collude corporations and
governments but i think that there's
this outside foreign entity that's doing
this to the united states because the
united states is very very unique and we
need to preserve it in my opinion but
other forces that doesn't register with
klaus he's not an american he never was
so it's a foreign concept to him what we
have here well you heard what jack
dorsey said uh you know it's a cliche to
bring up the dorsey podcast with rogan
that we did but
jack said we are working we we care to a
global audience not an american one and
right there it's like okay
he is telling us that their intention is
to subvert the american will that he
doesn't view the nation as even existing
on top of that you have people like
bernie sanders
he he tweeted out its two senators
should not be able to stop 48 senators
and 210 congressmen and women
it's like senator sanders there's 52
senators in opposition to you but he
doesn't view the other half of the
country as being part of the equation
so he's outright like you are not a part
of this
and then you you take a look at how big
tech acts
it feels like
it's funny when we have that we have
some guy super chat saying that you know
we we on this show and the friends of
this show are radicalized and i'm like
we are the ones who are like america
american history
constitution liberty that's not
radicalizing that status quo that's
being like this country is about
defending civil rights
granting them over time and protecting
the individual now we have a growing
faction of
internationalists and they say they are
authoritarians and they say that well
they lie about that because they don't
want to admit it but they show us they
are and it feels like
perhaps we get this wrong we talk about
the culture war and we say left versus
right or authoritarian versus
libertarian it is the soul of america
versus the conquering forces which are
destroying it and the conquering forces
make up tens of millions and are be and
control the institutions i think the
idea of saying the greater good has
accelerated the idea of of like this
global community like i care for
everybody but people who are saying
greater good lately they're also telling
me that they don't believe in things
like borders
and so
america doesn't it's an idea now it
doesn't exist right it's everybody else
outside um which we should all care
about people but
they've erased the borders
i think people need to understand
there's not going to be
like
any kind of
internationalism i mean that's what the
left literally calls they don't call it
globalism right will not actually happen
they don't they don't understand that
they are selling themselves out these
american leftists who are like i believe
in internationalism and it's like okay
what will really happen is that the
global powerful elites with with
powerful military forces will just
centralize their authority in their own
country and everyone else will be
subjugated it's not going to be like a
one world government it's going to be
the hunger games with capital city that
they live in well guarded and protected
and then you will lose everything and
you'll be happy so they say even more
terrifying is it's they don't even care
about the government's half the time
it's the corporations that they want to
govern like
it makes sense corporations can function
like authoritarian machines they can
distribute resources um
at their own whims and they can shut you
off if they want you know socially
they'll erase you it's incredible how
someone can get banned off of all these
social media networks and then have
their bank account shut down by paypal
and visa and like all at once like
within a day it can happen to someone
that's in completely i mean not i don't
like the word anti-american but i mean
it's the antithesis of of like of
individual freedom and liberty like
we're supposed to create a government to
protect our ability to communicate and
socialize
you know what i'll say this if america
cannot survive this it doesn't deserve
to
if if america does not have the the
resolve the strength the will and the
fortitude to survive the
authoritarianism that it's sweeping
across this country then then it should
one thing that could happen is it could
take over this thing and then it's like
we're under another corporate monarchy
for the next x amount of years and then
there's another revolution or we can
resist it and avoid that tyranny
at what point do they start actually
resisting
there this is a form of resistance just
by talking about them pointing out like
hey klaus schwab wants to have
corporations govern you right that's
that's a form of resistance and i don't
think that the pressure will ever stop
that's the thing when do we when do we
stop resisting i guess the censorship is
my biggest problem when it comes to like
erasing voices i think
people should be able to say what they
want and we could debate that and you
know i i always talk about the immune
system of your ideas it can only get
better if you put it out there to fight
something that you might not believe in
but you hear an idea maybe it makes your
idea stronger or you learn you were
wrong right if you censor all these
voices you don't have that anymore then
you're just in a corner and you can only
say one thing and then ideas stop
growing well then the powerful elites
can say what they want yeah and that's
what will happen for sure and that's and
that's what it means to have corporate
rules great advertising you know
corporate rule me it's it's it's
you know honestly it is communism and
it's not it's like it's like
neo-futuristic communism they don't
take over by force they take over by
selling you things you like they take
over by convincing you to give up your
rights and then eventually there's a
corporation
with a chairman
and they can decide
you have to do x if you want access to
why you if you want food then you work
for us oh it's a private company we can
do what we want
so when
court when when corporation x is more
powerful than the government
and the government can't protect its
people the government and the
corporation controls where you can go
and what you can say
and they do in many ways then eventually
you are just a part of an authoritarian
dictatorship i don't care what you call
it corporations don't grant you the same
you know don't protect your rights they
don't care you work for a fast food
restaurant they can actually at any
moment now there are some laws in the
public side to protect you but the
public side is just they're they're
they're they're colluding together and
if you think you have job security at a
corporation wait till they automate your
role and want to cut back on their
overhead and then you don't have really
any job security there's nothing not
that you have job security by nature but
it's not going to like enhance your
ability to work working for a
corporation as opposed to government
yeah people aren't working i drove down
here i saw a pen i saw panera somewhere
they were they were closed under staffed
sign on the door sorry i've been in this
pen and it's won like a ton of times on
the way down it's cascade failure man
yeah when when one store has 10 people
working and that's their and and they're
like slightly above the staff they need
for operation and then one person says
i quit i don't do this anymore or i have
to move my family's moving because of
kovac right now they're down to nine
people and they're like okay now we're
pushing it everyone's working a little
bit more than they'd like to but we can
maintain this and then someone goes i
didn't sign up for this i don't get paid
enough i quit now they're understaffed
then the people are just like dude i
can't work 60 hours i need a day off i
quit and then there's no one left and
they say with only five people we can't
keep this place open i'm sorry guys have
a nice day you're all fired so it's the
death of the smaller businesses
people don't want to work but they
worship corporations
and the country will become the
corporation
it's happening it's going to be like
idiocracy with costco
check out this story from the
independent
biggest crash in world history personal
finance expert robert kiyosaki predicts
economic crisis in october a crash is a
really good time to get rich says author
of rich dad poor dad now
i don't believe him
it's a bit much to be like this month
it'll happen
however i don't not believe him
you know because we just had bob murphy
on the economist phd economists say that
they remove the restriction required the
restrictions on on reserve fractional
reserve banking the reserve requirement
so basically banks can just
print money and give it out
yeah so let me just read a little bit
they say personal finance expert robert
kiyosaki warned the crash is coming
regardless of whether the u.s debt
ceiling is raised or what measures are
imposed by treasury secretary janet
yellen or federal reserve chair jerome
powell this is going to be the biggest
crash in world history we have never had
this much debt pumped up the debt to gdp
ratio is out of sight mr kiyosaki said
the stock market was being artificially
inflated by the treasury department and
the federal reserve with decisions
disconnected from the realities of the
current economy in the u.s
the reason why ms yellen and mr powell
are scrambling he said is they've
expanded the volume of money while the
velocity of money is plummeting as no
one spends and their crash and their
cash lingers in savings
he says quote
so they pump all this money and prices
go up
so it is a tren it is transitory
inflation but we're stacked with this
massive debt and all it's done is bump
up the stock market and real estate
market the money has not gone into the
economy that's the sad part so the rich
get richer but the poor and middle class
are getting poorer it's tragic what's
happening today
you can't keep printing fake money
that's not good
i've noticed it when i was buying my
crystals and rocks as i told you
especially my opals
people aren't spending so the people
that have this load of assets they need
to unload have to drop the price these
people are cutting slashing their prices
by 80 percent to offload their assets so
the rich people can buy up all the
assets now yeah because desperate people
are selling but that's non-essentials at
the same time the land for instance
people are like wow they're desperate to
get out of cities the stuff they really
need the prices are skyrocketing so
what's going to if there is a crash what
would happen to like land prices
skyrocket they would score here's here's
my bad there's a lot of arguments you
could give to why land would crash
because if people don't have money they
can't buy so that means people are
trying to sell we have to lower their
prices or it could be that land is a
necessity and people in cities who can't
afford to live anymore will be desperate
to leave so which will which will
put the pressure on those trying to
leave what we're seeing right now in my
opinion the crash is happening the m1
money stock is is insane even after they
change the the definitions and the rules
and you've got people trying to leave
cities for the country i've i'm seeing
it in these prices it is insane how much
money we have to spend to try and expand
even into west virginia because people
are like my garbage land is now worth
you know
a fortune
so what i think would happen is if the
crash gets worse it will just continue
the trend we're already seeing people in
new york will be like i don't need opals
please buy the opals for me i don't and
they're going to be like
what's it worth it's a hundred dollar
i'll give you 20 bucks fine please just
take it and by the way i can't do
anything with it i'm buying the opals to
teach children about rocks and stones
that's the investment
this is the point i've always made you
know when alex jones with santa's show
buy your gold people i'd be like okay
it's the apocalypse the economy is
crashing and i'm walking down the street
and i see a guy with a big old pile of
gold and i've got a sandwich in my hands
and he says hey i'll buy that sandwich
off off you for a piece of gold and i
say huh look to my right there's a guy
with a bottle of water and he says i'll
share my water with you and for some of
your sandwich and i'll be like i'm
thirsty and that's substantially more
valuable than a shiny rock
and they'll say hey you want water and
food but you don't have money for it
what do you what do you have to offer us
blood literally you can donate blood we
need your biometrics
i don't know
in an apocalypse like you know what
would you trade because what's going on
the apocalypse necessities are going to
skyrocket like water and food is going
to skyrocket yes and if people can't
afford it what do they have to offer
other than their own bodies this is yes
that's a good point but i i was i was
saying like in the analogy on the side
of the road i didn't quite understand
why someone inside a road would be like
i have an iv i know isn't that crazy but
yeah um people have to they'll do a lot
of things they'll do a lot of things
trying to survive but i asked this
question before
what is the one thing that is mo is the
hardest to produce but is extremely as
commonly used in homes
chemicals yeah
well i said antiseptics yeah
i don't think most people know how to
make an antiseptic you can probably make
a rudimentary alcohol if you know how to
you know distill things yeah but that's
not super easy so i'm thinking like what
is the hardest thing to produce that we
use every day soap
soap's not that hard to make it but but
yes relative to how frequently it's used
it's kind of soap is good but i feel
like antiseptics so i bought a bunch of
mouthwash and isopropyl alcohol and
hydrogen peroxide things that like in
the event of an injury you want to clean
your wound because back in the day you
gotta you stub your toe and it's like
chop your leg off you got an infection
yeah
one vitamins two
yes oh yeah yeah i think this that's one
of the positives over the last year and
a half of people realizing we should
take vitamins yep i take c d b and uh a
multivitamin and magnesium ever since
the the pandemic and that's almost zinc
as needed whenever people washing their
hands in public restrooms
there are a lot of people who have
urban property investments that are
going to drop to nothing
no one's going to want to be in new york
city when they're struggling to get
resources into the city it's so hard
yeah and so if you bought a condo or
apartment in new york i can't imagine
you're having a good go of it trying to
try to get out of there especially with
the with the lockdowns yeah like uh an
hour and a half of north of the new york
city
there are homes that were 200 thousand
dollars that are now 600 700 000
right and people are moving there and
it's like a lot of my friends i'm 36 a
lot of our parents moved up from the
city
in the 80s so they witnessed the
collapse of the city in the 70s when
everything was on fire and it was
terrible it was bankrupt um so now all
of that hour and a half north is kind of
full although people are now moving to
go maybe to florida
but the uh hour now north of us is
what's being filled in you know upstate
upstate real upstate new york have you
noticed
i don't know if you've checked city
prices though have they been going down
i haven't
i can't imagine yeah they're spiking
right now but you made a great point
that the the real value of city land is
not going to escalate if it gets
difficult oh it's going to be like
escape from new york people are a great
movie by the way great movies
i was i was there when when sandy hit
new york
and like i went to a bodega
i was like i'm hungry
bodega they had two guys standing
outside with two by fours and a line of
people waiting again one at a time they
were only allowed in and i went in the
guy said the stuff in the fridge is all
spoiled but the the dry goods are still
good and i was like okay and then i
looked in the fridge and it's like okay
the gatorade is still good you know the
the the sodas are just warm
but all the milk all the dairy all the
perishables just gone so this is an
interesting concept like
things that have value this is what i
was thinking about when people are
buying like even nfts i think nfts will
probably drop dramatically in value
there's an economic crash
yeah they're just art basically but
maybe not maybe not i mean that's one
way to use them as art you can do it for
contracts and stuff like that right
i think those i think nfts will probably
go down but i do think crypto would
skyrocket because people are going to
need a digital means of transaction in
the event it becomes harder with these
with you know the way banks operate but
we'll see i don't know if the banking
system would be you know as negatively
affected but if businesses are if banks
aren't going under and you know banks
are closing and then all of a sudden
you're you're like where's my where's my
money but i will say like
i think there are certain hard assets
that will become substantially less
valuable or stay the same and then
rural land is probably going to become
massively valuable realistically how
valuable is gold anyway
i mean i know it's useful as like a
superconductor but actually really
really valuable yeah for the common
person though no yeah it's really
valuable the problem is we value it for
it's like
you know it's it's
shining shininess instead of its
scientific processes right you know it's
it's a scarce
valuable object the scarcity drives it
we do use it in a lot of technologies
and it's extremely valuable in that
regard but we don't really value it for
that
that that value does help drive up the
cost though but i think
i don't know if i'll get to that point
with economic collapse where like a
bottle of water will be worth a hundred
dollars oh yeah that could happen easily
it could but i don't know if we'll get
to that point even if even if we face a
major economic crisis people still work
people still make stuff you know i'm
thinking about how crazy everything's
gotten and i'm watching fox news and i'm
like
you know what i realize people watch the
news and the news is doing the same
thing it always does the guy because you
know bill hammer's on tv and he's like
afghanistan happens and they assume like
see everything's fine like my because
they assume like the
tv would shut off like in the movies yo
go to any one of these countries look at
the history of any any one of these
countries i went the revolution even
afghanistan
the economy is still struggling along
even in afghanistan people are still
working people are still going out and
buying food it doesn't just cease to
exist so you can absolutely be watching
your tv program while the world is
collapsing around you not realizing
because this tv show is giving you this
like this veil they pick and choose the
apocalypse right like if it's a a
migrant caravan
a few years ago that's all we saw
on the news if it's in my micro caravan
now you don't really see much of it you
gotta go to voters attendance you gotta
go to the ventura report on instagram to
see jorge standing there recording them
taking votes across i think it was
talking about the border yeah you know
it's i don't think they're annoying i
think it's a huge story but yeah we had
i mean now they're estimating 400 000
migrants you know coming up the next
month i look at that and i'm just like
look
call it pessimistic or just call it what
it is
how can you watch all this happen and
then say tim is wrong the republic is in
good shape we had a guest on the show
i'm not going to call him out after the
show he was he asked me or like we were
talking i don't know if he asked me if i
brought it up something about like you
know you really think things are going
to fall apart and i was like they're
literally falling apart and he was like
nah i think it's fine i think this is
just like you know news and everything's
gonna be fine and then i was like
how can you witness the street violence
the shootings the firebombings the the
executive authority the rule by edict
the january what happened on january 6
antifa riots and just be like nothing is
happening i'm like yo history is
happening right now in your face but
you're a frog in a pot as the water is
turning up and you don't even realize it
yeah i'm always trying to make sure that
i'm not
saying that it's this is the end because
i'm always like kind of paranoid i'm
like this this has got to be the end but
then when it starts to be the end like a
covet hits and it starts to filter i'm
like no it's fine right
my grandfather was a cop in the city in
the 70s
that was the end for him right like but
also when he was younger he saw an atom
bomb fall out of the sky i mean he
thought it was the end then yeah but
this feels different maybe because we're
of a certain age and experiencing it we
might have families and houses and all
that stuff and all that's collapsing but
something does feel
different than what my grandfather would
tell me i think maybe the issue is that
we call it the end when it's not the end
it's a change the transition yeah for
sure you know the the american empire
uh couldn't last forever
soviets couldn't last forever
and that's what's happening you know so
i i said this the other day and maybe
it's a good thing maybe what happens is
if you live in new hampshire
all of a sudden the country breaks apart
the federal government has no authority
as we've already seen with california
sanctuary state decree the fed emperor
has no clothes so now all of a sudden
it's like okay you got no income tax and
you can have guns
i don't think people in new hampshire
are going to be upset about what's going
on and i think people will absolutely
adapt to the circumstances meaning
they'll raise their own food
there's you know people will it's gonna
be a hole in the market someone's gonna
be like hey now now that we're
struggling to get the imports in we
can't get avocados or strawberries
because those are seasonal and have to
cross you know very very far require a
lot
we uh we we don't have a whole lot of
food out here and someone's gonna be
like i could grow food and make money
doing it
farming will become more valuable it'll
go back to basics people start valuing
good hard work all over again there's a
lot of value in that because
people are gonna spend more time with
their families they're going to be more
responsible for themselves and get away
from this you know
i don't know
just start naming off the seven deadly
sins and you can describe new york city
yeah and that'll start changing maybe
for the better yeah that's why i'm not
completely depressed about everything it
seems it's really bad but
i like that i like that people are
returning to that kind of thing it's
actually a super red pill to me and this
is something that i've been talking
about a little bit because i feel like
you know the cycle weak men create bad
times bad times create strong men well
we're going into bad times we're going
to come up with some really strong
people i think that's good i think
that's positive and i think that's
something humans have been doing for
thousands of years there's no reason to
suspect that this would be any different
so to me that's very positive yeah yeah
my uh you know my grandparents their
parents fled pogroms in russia oh wow
there were people running to their towns
with axes whoa and hacking them up and
uh they left and it took a boat to here
and when they got there this is my
grandma's father
one of four children
he had a scab on his head they said you
got to go back
so she went back with the with the kids
to the pogroms and had to hide out for
the scab to heal and then take the boat
back
right oh my gosh that's apocalyptic
right yeah they made it and i i have a
grandmother they had to go back because
the scar would have given the person
away as a flear
it was it was it was like a from just
like a
cut that he had from something else but
it could be a disease or something could
be disease that's what they were
thinking yeah like they're like oh we
don't know what this is you could leave
the kid or send the kid back and you say
here um that's bold so think of that
look i want to pull up this article that
shane wrote
this is the beautiful ones in universe
25 rats hope and despair at the end of
the world this is about the rat utopia
experiment
and there was the title of it i think
you nailed the title because it's the
most interesting aspect to me the
beautiful ones
when i see what's going on now it feels
like i think it's kierkegaard's clown
where he comes out and he warns
everybody there's a fire but they all
laugh and then he finally says no no
there's a fire they laugh even harder
and yeah you know there's that idea but
then there's also while all this cast is
happening
you have what i view to be as a as a
cult that just blindly believes the
media the media is just overtly lying
all the time to make money so you've
basically got
a sinking ship while people are stealing
from the pockets of these people while
they're distracting them and it's just
like it's going down
and then meanwhile there are these shows
where people are glorified and glammed
up and they're dancing and i'm like
those are the beautiful ones
they're just they're just grooming
themselves and beautifying themselves as
everything goes into chaos
but you break this down for us and
explain to us the beautiful ones and
then you know yeah john b calhoun is a
scientist who started making these rat
utopias and um he would take
four males four females put them in a
little he called universe and let them
exponentially grow those early
experiments they were just kind of like
overcrowded so they just like clump up
here come up there and he would stop it
have to start over
but universe 25 was with mice and that's
when he basically he gives them
everything they need all the food all
the water
all the medicine there's no sickness
there's no hunger the only thing that's
lacking is space
and um
i think he did something with like
powder food on one side and like nicer
food in the middle which kind of created
a kind of like a city and a country type
vibe interesting yeah but the beautiful
ones
would emerge in these universes when the
population was about to hit equilibrium
so like universe 25 could hold about 3
000 or so mice
um and i think around 2000 is when the
beautiful ones would emerge
and they're these mice that just stopped
caring about mating
they stopped caring about anything they
just kind of groomed themselves and
became beautiful
they did nothing um and around this time
is when it would start to collapse
behavior they would call he would call
it the behavioral sink you know it would
just uh
like total insanity the mothers would
have been in their kids um there's like
mice mating male mice mating with male
mice and there's uh um they're attacking
the kids
and it got ugly um hyper crowding too
right like they'd all cluster in one
area yeah yeah i mean at a certain point
it was just so much that he believed
that when there was no space left there
was no feeling of um
like you had to do anything to survive
it was all you're doing right so you're
getting attacked you're hiding um and
then the dominant mice would try to
protect their like you know their city
of women so mice were getting attacked
as well yeah there's violence were
people leaving the beautiful ones alone
yeah i i don't they might have been
attacked but they were kind of like
alone on the sides you know were they
being just taking selfies
at first i thought it was behavioral
sync as in synchronization but it's
behavioral sync like sinking you're
going down
yeah
so as i stated this in the intro that
maybe the inbreeding had something to do
with the disassociation dissociative
behaviors since it all came from eight
mice maybe because i did have mice as a
child and one of them i would i saw some
inbreeding and some deformities came out
in the mice um did he like destroy the
deformed
child did he destroy mice i don't know
about destroying them but he would pluck
the ones that survived the collapse and
try to put them into new universes and
they were so traumatized they couldn't
shake you know their violent behavior
maybe traumatize is the right word maybe
programmed developed into this reality
sure true and so that spells very
there's a lot of people actually in the
piece you talked to brett weinstein yeah
and he's like well they use lab mice
they don't use wild mice right
for every experiment right yeah and so
that means in the wild the parents
transfer knowledge some knowledge to
their children but you know a good
example is and i love bringing up the
chickens is that we have three babies
that uh
were raised away from the parent
chickens and they don't know how to eat
bugs and i'm like i don't know how to
teach them how to eat stink bugs the
other babies
they can you can learn oh right i can
eat it
but because they look to me like a
parent you know i put the stink bug and
then they just look at me like what's
this and they don't do it the other
chickens we had were raised around only
other chickens so they see a bug they
immediately go after it
that that knowledge transfer didn't
occur with these and that's why i was
reading they say like you typically if
you want to have chickens you want the
chickens to be raised to be born by
other chickens or like raised with them
so that they can learn from them
these lab mice don't have that yeah so
that could be a major factor in why we
are not going down that path but just to
say one more thing
when i see these videos on youtube
when i see that some of the most
prominent and popular youtubers are
quite literally the beautiful ones i'm
like yo i think we're in the right
utopia i think it's happening like what
i was saying earlier too is i think
it used to seem like the elites were the
only ones who could become the beautiful
ones they would have the money the space
but with things like tick tock and
filters people can just curate whatever
best beautiful self they want to make up
tutorials makeup tutorials everything um
surgery if you can do that but
everyone's a beautiful one now
we're below replacement level
reproduction so it's like
you know what you know what what's
interesting is
he did you did say he tried to have like
a rural and city kind of vibe to certain
you know to talking to the universes
but people who live out in the middle of
nowhere who are more self-sufficient
probably aren't experiencing what the
cities are experiencing so
there there's economic constraints that
make someone trapped in this space right
people say i'm in the city i can't
afford to leave
so that is what keeps them in that
universe
although they could physically walk out
they don't because they don't know how
to survive
otherwise people live in rural areas are
more independent and more likely to have
the skills to survive on their own not
absolutely but more so so they aren't
experiencing the behavioral sync the
rural people tend to be conservative and
they're watching the city people
the beautiful ones and the chaos and the
fighting and the violence and they're
saying stop
but you can't shake what you described
as the trauma from them
yeah i think the internet has collapsed
space though so like maybe a lot of the
children in the rural
like places they are able to be the
beautiful ones online and also there's
consequences of the cities and the
policies that are affecting the country
too gas prices are messing up farmers
who have to are truckers you know like
this is the first time in my life since
i've been driving that i can travel the
country and see the gas prices be the
same actually i could usually go south
and expect it to be definitely way lower
yeah it's the same everywhere it's
almost four dollars by me wow uh but
it's like three thirty three fifteen
around here three thirty
shocking you know i'm thinking that the
the behavioral sync world the universe
is like the internet so these people
that are in the internet all the time
are in that confined space and it's
driving them insane yeah yeah i think
overcrowding is technically the
psychological effects of density
so that would make sense because it's a
dimension where you we've in like covet
i think
we've uploaded our identities onto the
internet more than maybe ever right
every we zoom to work
we see family for
you know doing uh however we're doing
covid on zoom like i know some people
who haven't seen their family in a year
yeah it's it's pretty wild so people
that's the real space now and this is
one of the reasons i'm adamant i'm like
we don't do we don't do um zoom or skype
stuff like we do in person shows and i
get a lot of really prominent people who
are like can't you just do it for me and
i'm like sorry man it's funny because
when we tried inviting these leftists
they're like tim won't do remote because
he's a coward i'm like if you had any
idea the people i rejected
and how famous and big because i won't
do remote stuff yeah that's just not
true but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna air
anybody's business
you know we've had a few people
um
many of them aren't in aren't in the u.s
they can't even travel here anymore
mm-hmm so uh
you know not to no you know i don't want
to i don't name anybody because people
might be like yo don't drag me into
anything but there's there's a lot of
people of like medium followings to
large followings some of them uh
are like moderate some are very
conservative some are prominent
internationally
they don't want to do it it's this
there's something very visceral about
being in in close proximity with someone
in communication body language you can
hear them vibrating i mean i know that's
funny to think of but it's very low
frequency you can hear people vibrating
whether you realize it or not you can
smell them it's amazing you don't feel
me vibrating right now i feel you thank
you i thought somebody was like
thank you
for a pyramid right there but no i was a
i was a
professor for like 10 years and um
in person is the best i was i would sit
just like this with a room of students
and we would write and you could hear
like
if someone was reading something they
just wrote and it was clicking with
everybody the root the silence you could
hear you could feel the silence right so
when we're when kovitt kicks us all home
we're on zoom
that's gone
there's no
like it's there's no interacting anymore
at all like they didn't feel um as
comfortable and it has i think it has to
do with analog sound and digital sound
with digital sound you can't have a one
and a one active everything else has to
be at zero for one to translate but with
analog we can put one and one together
and have these weird harmonies
so that's in person we have analog but
the digital transformation i've done
i've done some stuff uh
ben shapiro had me before and he was
like do you want to do the show and i
was like to be great and we did it
remote and it was actually really hard
because i had to record it and then take
the memory card and then have it driven
to a place to upload because the
internet is not good enough at the time
we had to we had to install the internet
lines here as like a very a lot of
construction work
and i was like
it it you know it was cool to talk to
ben he's a cool dude and but it just
really felt like i would talk and then
pause and then he would talk and then
pause and you don't get those moments
where like out of nowhere you know ian
might just blurt out the vibrations of
the universe and yeah
those are human moments that make
something feel a lot eye contact you
can't make eye contact online at all
yeah maybe if they put cameras in the
middle of the screen behind the screen
and then you might feel like you're
making eye contact that's a good idea
actually weird thing but it might they
might we should also use sapphire for
the screens i think sapphire
i think it don't dude have you seen a
star sapphire and then you look through
a lens that's pointed at this at the sun
and you see that same star pattern i
think that if you use sapphire lens that
it might help in high high brightness
that would cause ideas i believe you'll
experiment i think people uh just feel
a lot of at least my students because
they were they're much younger right um
they do feel more comfortable online
but they were comfortable to be quiet
right right like because they're usually
just very quiet online
but their their real world was also
taking over their internet space so we'd
be in class technically on zoom but i
would have a kid like a mcdonald's
drive-through
like just ordering food
have you seen that viral video where the
kid uses a green screen or whatever
and so it's like he was out with his
friends or something i remember what it
was but he's trying to use like a
background and the teacher was like i
can tell
so you were
ferris bueller of zoom yeah you were a
teacher with in classrooms and then it
you were there for the transition into
the covid yeah zoom what was that like
um i remember so it was two different
schools one was a community college and
one was a private school and which are
very it was interesting to see like kids
with who came from money in a private
school and
kids from the community in the community
college um
but
for the most part they felt like it was
the end times and i kept telling them
it's not
wow this is before this is before we
locked down in new york all that stuff i
was like it's gonna be fine and i told
the whole spiel of my grandfather and
all that stuff like okay good and then a
week later we were kicked off back to
zoom and i'm i'm terrible with computers
so i'm like
you know just clicking away trying to
make it work but um
i thought it was horrible i i hate
teaching on zoom um and it was you just
lost that human aspect and uh i think
especially when you're trying to create
things like it was creative writing
classes
um you can't do it man it's not it's not
possible it didn't work you know because
we have to do workshops and kids have to
like
look at you in the face and be like i
like this part but this part not so good
you could do this in that and on zoom
you're just brady bunching you know
around and it doesn't just doesn't feel
right um so i think it's horrible but
then kids got really comfortable doing
it right a lot i think a lot of people
like it now for lack of resistance it's
easier because it's more comfortable but
comfort is not the way to get stronger
often you need discomfort but this is
the only way this is unfortunately
still a net positive yeah kids are more
likely to younger younger people are
more likely to be at home now their
parents are more likely to spend time
with them and their parents are more
likely to know what they're being taught
in schools so remote remote learning has
not been a bad thing in my opinion other
than it's better for the kids to be in
person
but when the parents started getting
wind over the teachers were sang and
there was that viral video where the one
teacher was like the parents can't find
out what we're telling their children
you know it'll be bad for us and what
we're trying to do yeah all of a sudden
the parents were like we can hear you we
can see this stuff yeah get away from my
children i was talking i mentioned this
to you earlier i was talking with ben
stewart about technology and the
advancement it's like every technology
is both good and bad everything is a
variance on some level and we have to
kind of
or locate where the badness is and where
the goodness is i agree yeah yeah like
dynamite
you know they called uh alfred nobel the
merchant of death he saw his obituary
accidentally printed and then freaked
out that's what they're calling me and
you know i guess i guess the idea for
dynamite was like easier mining you
could plant the explosive leave and then
no one would it boom and then it falls
down but they were like you made a
weapon the technology wasn't meant to be
evil or destructive in the sense that it
would hurt people it was meant to make
things safer and easier but it was a
powerful weapon so i always tell people
no matter what you do you will help
someone and you will hurt someone
and i i don't mean to be completely
absolute like sure like you could jump
and click your heels and it affects
nothing or nobody in fact it might make
someone happy but i'm talking about you
know your political aim when you're like
i believe in universal health care and
so we're going to vote for this and then
there's some you know person who's price
whose taxes go up because of it another
budget disrupted in some retirees being
hurt by it there's there's there's no
neutral action like you know you can try
to do better and we can try and err on
the side of maximizing good but you'll
ultimately always hurt someone and i
think it's an important thing to mention
because you may one day be the nicest
person in the universe who saved a
billion babies lives and then one day
one dude shows up and he's just like you
did this to me
and i started thinking about this you
know why the sixth sense
the movie bruce willis character wins
that award he wins an award for his
amazing work with child psychology and
then one day there's some dude in his
underwear like you lied to me and then
shoots him and so here's a guy who was
doing as good as he could but he hurt
that kid
and so i mean that's not a perfect
example because what i'm talking about
is kind of like a butterfly effect thing
as well
you know you you you find a good parking
space your your friend is like hey can
you find me a parking space i'm going to
be late so you do and then someone else
pulls up and they're like he just took
the space i needed
you know there's it's it's a better
example might be the law of equivalent
exchange
you know full metal alchemist you you
have to get something to give something
give something to get something and that
means some people will be on the short
end of the stick yeah i remember um
there was a book i read i don't remember
what book was a long time ago where the
guy was wishing for a million he kept
wishing for money and he's like oh my
gosh this cube gives me every time i
wish for money it appears in my room but
it was disappearing from somewhere else
in the universe well that's like the
monkey's paw story right you got you
know the monkey spot obviously i think i
do you know the monkey swap
we're going there
you wish on it and then the finger curls
but it twists your wish so the best
example is you know someone finds the
paw and it says it's got you know three
wishes and they go i wish for one
million dollars and the finger curls and
then their phone rings and they're like
is this mr johnson it's like it is
i have one million dollars for you and
they go oh it goes because your father
died and his insurance is paying out and
they go no
so you get the money but you have to
give something exchange yeah typically
wow be careful what you wish for yeah
there's a i think there's a balance like
that in a lot of things you know i
noticed that just in losing people you
know i know a few people and myself
included who lost a few dear ones a few
years ago and then there's there's kids
all of a sudden like life just seems to
balance out you know you lose and then
and then there's kids that's not as
scary as a monkey's possible social
media is scary though like it is the
monk we've created the monkeys paw gave
us this mass communication social media
i'm terrified about the badness of it
like i want to focus on you know i'll be
honest all i i believe a good portion of
the world's problems would end overnight
if communications around the world were
shut down for like one week yeah we're
just talking about the earth started to
heal during covet i don't know if
there's like if that's actually real but
like the uh the what was it the
magnetosphere or like uh the ozone
opened up and then it sealed up again
well yeah i was saying the part where
people were home and not commuting as
much they said the the earth was not as
it was not vibrating as much as it used
to vibrating yeah
if we shut if if not if we shut down but
it's just for whatever reason
all social media
all television shows all information
exchange except for human contact was
suspended for a week i believe all of
this would would all the crisis would
would probably stop when we were in
chicago i was living in my room at eric
paske and the electricity went out and i
was like what what do we do he was like
want to make soup
some soup and sat and talked yeah right
but think about this we had uh yasi
gastetneron he's jewish and he talks
about you know the sabbath and how they
don't go on the computers they just hang
out with family and talk
and that has been stripped away
from
our society for the most it's why shows
like this are so popular i think that's
why i love rogan's for so long is just
watching two guys hang out and talk i
felt like i was there with him yeah
exactly yeah you know it's like getting
that time where you're just hanging out
with friends and listening
and uh man we used to do that when we
were kids and we would talk about crazy
stuff i'd be hanging at my friend's
house playing knights of the old
republic they'd be stoned off their
asses and they'd be like dude what if
like the universe
it's like actually like only five
dimensions but we can't tell and it's
like just saying weird stuff i thought i
was i think that's true though yeah
probably on some level
i would i would imagine that the entire
universe as we know it is falling
it it light speed towards a brick wall
but we wouldn't know because it's all
falling at the same rate so it's
relative it just looks like it's sitting
still to us
yeah there's there's four dimensions
we're moving through or there's three
dimensions there's four dimensions we're
moving through and only three we can
control yes and the fourth dimension
time is like we're in free fall
you can't
so imagine you're imagine imagine you
fall you know off the grand canyon
you're just falling or you fall off a
plane and you're falling towards the
earth you can move in two dimensions
you know up down left right but you're
going down
and then eventually you're headed
towards that
so that that's like time
you can't turn around and go back
unless you have a jet pack yeah which
you don't yeah and you die
yeah you can kind of video
we kind of reference the past with video
it's a sort of time travel where you can
watch past events but we're not quite
five senses of past experience yet that
might come though but it's is it really
time travel if you just think you're
seeing it
it depends you know we've upload if
we've uploaded our identities into the
internet and that's what's real that's
what's real you know it'll be crazy
so we've used all the social media and
they talk about how we're programming
this great ai with all of the stuff we
do so when you go when you like
recapture for instance biggest scam on
the planet
so you try to log into a website and it
says to it to to prove you're human
please click these buttons and like
prove this the computers already know
for the most part what they're doing is
they're having you
teach the computer what certain things
are
so here's how it works
they say
please click all the street lights in
this photo and then you do
the issue is the actual captcha is your
mouse movements
they know if you're human or about based
on how the mouse is moving on the screen
so they don't need you to actually do
this labor to train an ai
here's here's a good sci-fi novel
one day
you're online and all of a sudden you
see a post on your own twitter that you
didn't make and you're like whoa i i
didn't post that someone must hack my
account and then you can't log in and
then you look at your facebook and your
youtube there's a video on youtube of
you talking and you're like i didn't
record this video
and what's actually happened is that
everything about your personality the
way you speak the way you think the
ideas you have your birthday was encoded
into the ai and then a digital version
of you was created and begins
propagating content based off of a
fictional lot like an art an ai version
of you and then you like look at your
phone and you're like what is it you get
a phone call and you're like it's from
me and you answer it and it's like
look at look at me
i am tim now and you're like no no this
is this can't be real and then all of a
sudden like like almost like body
snatchers are zombies
artificial intelligence versions of
people's personalities emerge it's going
to go like over i'm the tim you want and
it'll be coded to give that person a
tailored team experience so based on
what they think you want that ai is
going to say oh it's going to be then
one day then one day you're like then
then you get the call and you're like
this can't be and then you drop your
phone and then you you're like you run
outside and you're like your phone's not
working anymore because the and then all
sudden you open your door and there's
this sil silver looking robot structure
that just grabs you by the throat and
then from the fingertips so it's turning
into looking like you
and then it's like i am the perfect
version of you
and then all of a sudden all over all
these cities there's just all these
robots these digital versions taking
over and then like when we talked about
the transport problem do you die when
the transporter teleports you from one
place or another because it breaks down
your body and reconfigured somewhere
else the entire planet is overwritten by
ai artificial versions of the people who
are using the computers
but all of them just act like they're
you
your soul is gone your existence is gone
but humanity stays the same except for
the robots when it comes to the
transporter problem i think you don't
die if you're because what i imagine
what we are right now we think of
ourselves as solid but what seems like
is happening all these these things
called spinners subatomic spinning
momentum things are coming together to
form atoms which bond and then so we're
appearing in place due to the spin of
this area if that if that spin is in a
different area it appears in place over
here it's appearing in place constantly
so if you appear here and now you appear
here it's still you appearing i would
imagine that the soul like magnetically
locks onto your formation of body
don't we shed ourselves like every seven
years so isn't it yeah isn't
transporting just like an accelerated
process of that so if we're still alive
yes yeah
but we don't shed our souls no i don't
know i wonder if the soul is like
magnetically attached to your form
bro we were talking about when we talked
about this with alex jones and michael
malus where like you take dmt and then
we're basically just meat puppets for
the machine elves or something
so like your soul is not even in this
reality these are just you know meat
vessels we walk around and and then when
you die you just snap through the veil
and you're a machine elf or something i
i can feel sheamus's soul right now i
think i feel bad that he's not i feel
like he should be in the room because
he's like no you guys that's not it this
is not the way
i think there's i think the
interdimensional spaces it will be next
i think we're going to start exploring
that i really do like what we're doing
i've been talking dmt
true true i've been talking to too many
uh alien abductees who believe that um
you know the aliens are us from or
versions of us from other dimensions
outer space like let's uh let's hear
some of these stories what's what's
what's really
with the aliens yeah like have you heard
a story that's kind of like rocked you
to your core
i wish i could say that but i i i have
met people who are cause i'm such a
skeptic
like
that's what i want to believe i really
do want to believe and i'm willing to
talk to everybody but i've met i met one
person in particular
we talked for like two hours before we
even got to aliens normal stuff
newspapers just like media
culture
really really got down and you were like
who'd you vote for and he was like oh my
god oh by the way oh yeah basically
basically i was just like so oh about
the abduction story um and he's been
abducted since he was nine and he's he
has a support group
for ufo abductees or people who've had
encounters and so they share these
stories but he's been abducted since he
was nine
and he has very very vivid memories of
being lifted out of his window
looking over uh peekskill new york which
is the town where the yellow brick road
was the original yellow brick road wow
yep and um and and kind of hovering over
the trees and he believes that uh the
beings that come for him
are like avatars
for beings that can't travel
um from other if they're far away play
from like far away planets he's like
they're they're controlling them because
they have like a hive mind
and they're like opening his skull and
he and he says he wakes up feeling these
things and
he has a phd in the spiritual awakening
of being abducted it's fascinating like
it's an actual phd or you're just saying
figuratively no yeah yeah not like me
where i bought one for twenty dollars he
has an actual one so he thinks that
they're electromagnetic drones
essentially like they're pilots they're
electromagnetic i don't know if he knows
he's touched he says he's touched them
and they they have a uh like a hot
sensation he remembers like recoiling
but this has been happening since to him
since he was nine
and they keep coming for him different
ones
you know we all know about the greys
that's what i asked him so he also
claims to be like a psychic and i asked
them if are the aliens coming
are you a psychic as a consequence of
the abductions or
because you're a psychic is that why
they're coming to you because he would
he would fix computers for a living in
like the 70s after he got back from
vietnam 70s 80s he's running around
fixing like machines and computers
he never talked about being abducted
because there's a stigma you don't want
to talk about that with people
so but people would keep coming up to
him and just talking about being
abducted they have the urge to tell him
like they're weird not abduction stories
all the time but like we saw ufo
something like that
and then uh you know i think his wife
might have been the first person he told
you know after uh
30 years of not telling anybody
so
i want to say i believe him you know
he's
he's it sounds crazy like he sounds
his story is like i sounds legit to me
like
but i also think
sometimes people might confuse
horrible dreams
and their reoccurring nightmare but i
also have then listened to um
different psychiatrists who say there's
no way to like
have trauma from such an experience like
these people who claim to be abducted
they have some type of trauma they can
be hypnotized and they relive it i know
people i've known people throughout my
life with schizophrenia
and i have heard stories about weird
government abductions and experiments
and i'm just like the things they say
are overtly insane it's one thing to be
like you need to believe me man guys in
suits came to my house yesterday and i'd
be like okay i mean but when they say
things like they have nanotechnology
devices that they've injected me with
that cause invisible cameras to circle
that my head at all times and i'm like
nothing's happening am i missing it
where is it can you tell me where it is
i'm like that's you know objectively
nuts i have a theory about schizophrenia
i think they're plugged in to a
mind level that we don't understand it's
kind of it's kind of a sad thought
though i mean some people may just have
misfiring brains for sure you know and
they need help but
yeah i'm like what if my friend is
telling me the truth they're actually
seeing something that's that's real
and we are just sitting here like
because look i've had friends who are
they can have a conversation and they
can tell you like this is a bottle of
water i need to drink water and eat food
i went to work today and then they'll
say something like i can see the beings
and you're and people will tell them
they're crazy and they're schizophrenic
and it's just like imagine if they
really did like in the sixth sense the
kid can see the dead people but they
just tell him he's crazy or in um
constantine it's a good example
in uh in constantine the movie he's like
growing up he could see all these things
you could see the angels and the demons
and then nobody believed and they
thought he was crazy and they put them
in hospitals
imagine being told you're crazy when
you're the one who's right because you
can see something that people can't do
that's like the problem
i was gonna talk about okay yeah yeah
but yeah sure
you're crazy that's not real it never
happened
did they just confirm that though yeah
it took the corporate media but um
i think schizophrenia people with
schizophrenia
are kind of plugged into a like an
information dump right they can't turn
it off and not to say that kids are
schizophrenic but there's a there's like
a lack of filter between them and the
world
like i think when we grow up we start to
uh take on all of like the substance of
materialism and we start we start to
think of like uh
just the routine of life but kids are
still thinking about aliens and ghosts
and monsters like my five-year-old all
the time every night that's all we talk
about and when i talked i had a friend
who was schizophrenic as well that's all
he talked about i'm like maybe they're
just like sensing something that we just
can't perceive right now
um or yeah my kid is just crazy no i
think remote v viewing that's a cia
project the cia investigates it because
it's that seemingly legit and there's
stories about people that died
no not yet yeah project looking glass i
think maybe is something that's targeted
was the one and i think it changed names
yeah and then you get this these
anecdotal stories of people that die on
the operating table and then they they
are above their body watching and they
hear the doctors saying things and then
somehow they come back to life after a
couple minutes and then they they recall
the conversation the doctor was like how
did you remember because they were they
were there on the bed maybe they were
dead but they weren't
completely unconscious crazy but they
see themselves from above you know yeah
but that and they see them like what
color she was wearing and yes but if so
the problem with standing the problem
with that is is you know you could be
semi-conscious and see a pink pink
scrubs and see a doctor you hear what
they say and afterwards you're like you
were talking about your football game
and the nurse was wearing pink scrubs
and like how did you know that but the
crazier stuff i read about was that they
would put numbers on the tops of things
and there were people who could tell you
they'd be like on the top of the monitor
was the number six and they would be
like what so you could be like you
weren't able to see measuring i know i'm
probably bastardizing you the word mag
vibration but you can measure the
vibration around you and basically
measure the matrix all you need to know
is where something is how much of it
there is and what it is and then you can
map that onto a three-dimensional grid
on a xyz axis and build the matrix so if
you're feeling the vibration of the
matrix you may be able to calculate what
everything is that's causing that
vibration and maybe on some subtle level
people are picking up on that because
how else would you see a six on top of a
monitor
they would have like
cards and stuff with information on it
that could only be seen from looking
down
and there would be people who would be
like i saw this card and it said these
things they'd be like whoa
i was trying to uh help solve a serial
killer case a few years ago the long
island series long island serial killer
and through that i was talking to some
cops who used people who tried remote
viewing to find bodies because this
particular killer left like a basically
a graveyard in long island
body parts all over the place that would
match with other parts of long island it
was and parts that were there for like
one part they found a torso in the
middle of long island they found the
hands 30 years later whoa yeah
but there was a guy in norway and a guy
i think in jersey who were trying to
like find
you know remote view you know and the
guy in norway supposedly according to
the reports out there i talked to him he
helped find a body
and just sitting in a room just like
doing what he does i i tried reaching
out to him to help find uh some some
people because we still don't know who
some of the victims are
but they like he act they gave them
information doesn't that person
but don't they become a suspect at that
point
he should where's the body
yeah i had this great source and now
he's in jail
you should uh you should uh i don't know
if i told this before look you should
check out the istal woman and the talmud
shut case yeah you did
that's
the ice woman of norway dude it's a
crazy story it was what was that deal
was it so a woman was found like dead of
smoke inhalation with a bunch of
passports or something right and there's
a bunch of like questions about who she
was how she died and i think the
prevailing theory is that she was a
mossad agent tracking down nazis
and one of the nazis she was tracking
down to assassinate got the best of her
oh that's good crazy stories yeah
nowhere
this is what's really crazy is like i
think about history
i think about stories like that and i'm
like you know the craziest thing is
a large portion of our history is
probably
the result of a deep conspiracy we'll
never know about
true history is probably long forgotten
and long lost because you can look at it
today a news article will come out and
they'll say something that's like
technically the truth
you know and then uh i'll give you a
good example like newsweek wrote about
the trump supporters wanting to secede
and the biden voters also agreeing and
they said trump voters want the country
to break apart what they didn't include
was like yeah but 41 percent of widen
voters agreeing is like a substantive
number so it's not only trump supporters
but history will record the framing of
it so i think back to like
you know there are a lot of people who
are like i don't appreciate how you said
this about this person because it makes
it sound like x when it's more like why
and some people just disagree on framing
when you look back at history history
being written by the winners it's not
just that it's like
you know we hear these famous quotes
benjamin franklin is better than 100
guilty persons escaped and one innocent
person suffer and he could have maybe
what he said or wrote down was
substantially more crass or crude and
then later on someone who knows and
loved him said i'm gonna remove that
swear word and clean it up and so so
there's a lot we think we know about
history our modern perception is based
upon what is most likely fabrications
and exaggeration have a good example of
this so and i mentioned this skeleton in
our first episode that's out now um in
my town we have a missing skeleton
problem
by that wait wait wait there's one
there's by that i mean there's one
missing skull okay
imagine uh no well we don't know
technically if it's more than one but
anyway
there's this local legend uh of a woman
named margaret corbin who was fighting
in the revolution where she was actually
on the sidelines as her husband was
manning a cannon
and the story goes that
he was murdered he was they got him she
took over the cannon she started firing
and then she was they
she became a prisoner of war and
margaret came back to my town and
it was like a she had horrible um
wounds from being shot
and just kind of lived at her life
we have a like a statue for her she we
buried her in this amazing place in west
point new york with the military academy
but she wasn't always buried at west
point she used to be buried in the
neighboring town highland falls
and in like 1920 or so the daughters of
the american revolution wanted to honor
her
and so they only by hearsay there was a
steamboat captain captain pharaoh who
said i know where she's buried it's
right here
everyone knows so they dug up the body
they had the uh the surgeon from west
point go and look at the skeleton say
yup looks like the description of
margaret and they put her in her new
grave and uh
i i happen to know the guys who were
fixing a wall by her new grave and this
is 2016
or maybe 17.
they accidentally disturbed her grave
and they had to and then bones came up
out of the ground
and they had to do the whole clean it up
situation and uh some scientists from
binghamton university came down they got
the bones they said this is a man
this is not a woman what and uh it's not
as old as you think uh
so what happened right
i did a lot of digging i i'm pretty
close with our historian
she has all the records and i found all
the records
dating back between the daughters of the
american revolution and the
superintendent of west point and some
other people because another church
wanted her remains and um
they just started making up a history of
her they said well she was born in
ireland and this person knows she was
born in holland falls you're like okay
well just just go with highland falls
down so like that starts to erode this
whole story because like if that's not
the case and what about the cannon case
so we don't know who the skeleton is and
we don't know where she actually is
right what if she's never existed i
don't think she existed because if i'm
driving here
there's uh molly corbin right look at
molly corbin it's the same story
i had margaret corbin really molly
corbin legend i think a lot of little
towns just made their own version and it
could have happened you know what you
should write about resurrection mary you
know the story of resurrection mary no
do you no
oh this is chicago folklore man oh yeah
and and you're probably gonna debunk it
because the urban legends we're told
are so different from reality but i grew
up on the south side uh i live just off
of archer avenue archer goes from the
city
southwest towards
the suburbs
becomes old archer road and then you get
into like um i think it's willowbrook so
the story is
and you you you'll probably look it up
and hear something different from what
we are told but we were told when we
were younger there's
oh this is i'll tell you my personal
experience too
there was a long time ago a young woman
went to the willowbrook dance hall off
of archer avenue it's in a very it's
very wooded it's like a forest preserve
area
and something happened where she decided
to walk home she was upset with her date
or something and as she was walking home
she got struck by a car it was a hit and
run i think it was like the 50s they say
something like that and she died
since then this has been what it's a
it's a vanishing hitchhiker story that
people have said they've been driving
down the road and they see a young
blonde woman wearing a dress hitchhiking
or asking for a ride there's a whole
bunch of weird things that happen like
they'll see her walking forward and
they'll see from behind and then when
they drive past her and look back she
has no face
or there are stories that a young blonde
woman in a dress will ask for a ride
home and get in the vehicle and then
when they're driving the driver will say
like okay now where do i go and i'll
look at there's no one there anymore
one story was that i think it was a cab
driver had picked up a young blonde
woman off archer avenue because these
stories stretch all the way into the
city
and said that she gave she said just
keep driving down arch and i'll tell you
when to stop
when he eventually was coming up to
resurrection cemetery which is on archer
as well
she said here here and then he pulls
over to stop looks over and see the
cemetery and says there's nothing here
and he looks and she's gone now here's
what gets crazy
this part is the urban legend part which
i'm pretty sure can be debunked but this
is what we're told growing up in chicago
that one point
somebody who was working the cemetery
saw
burns like molding in the gates of the
cemetery as if hands were squeezing the
gates trying to pull them apart like
they were trying to get in
and what had happened was they said no
no this is just a car you know a truck
accidentally backed into it and dented
the bars so we're gonna get it fixed
the urban legend they tell again this is
probably all apocryphal just kids
scaring each other was that after they
got it fixed one day people started to
notice the paint was coming off and the
bends were coming back
like she was still trying to get in but
i'll tell you my story man when i
started uh i was i was in chicago and i
was with some friends and i was like we
should actually do an investigation and
ask people they've seen it if there's
been any sightings so i lived near
midway airport and the stories actually
go well past my house and this is in the
city proper now you got to drive like i
don't know it's maybe like 10 miles down
archer it's it's a straight road then it
slowly starts winding and then becomes
very very much a forest preserve and so
to hear a ghost story in a city like
this you're like the airport's right
there but there were stories of people
finding her and picking her up so we
decided
we're gonna go and and go to the go to
the area because there's this cafe we
used to hang out all the time called the
ashbury which is also they say is
haunted like people have been pushed
down the stairs and stuff creepy stuff
it's also in a very wooded area
so we start asking questions
and then at some point right around the
time we're digging into this the willow
brook dance hall where the story started
burnt to the ground and it burned to the
ground in october like just before
halloween or something so we were like
dude we're so freaked out and a lot of
people didn't want to talk they were
like i don't want to be involved in this
and i was like they probably get so much
of this people coming and asking them
questions but there's another uh story
from chicago and it's the midlothian
turnpike you don't want you want you
want to know about this one yeah the
legend we're told in chicago is that
it's where al capone dumped all the
bodies
and so it's considered to be like it's
called bachelor's grove i think it's
what it's called it's been a long time
since i've but
creepy stuff happens there not just
because the legend of like al capone
would go to the bog and dump a body
where it would sink but because of those
legends and the ghost stories
creepo's would go there and do creepy
stuff like chicken slaughtering and
there are stories of like people like
teenagers when we were teenagers people
would be like yo let's go to bachelor's
grove and it's like off the midlothian
turnpike and then we we'd go there and
i've been there
scary and creepy and they try to like
trick kids and go into going the wrong
path so they don't actually go to the
it's an old cemetery
and
there are stories
where like people would go there and
there would be like some kind of
i i don't think it's right to say devil
worshiper because satanists aren't like
cloak-wearing occultists but occultists
would be there like killing chickens and
then spilling blood and like doing
creepy stuff so like the scariest thing
about the story is not the ghosts they
say it's one of the most haunted
locations in the country maybe even the
world the scary stuff to me was whenever
like someone would be like you want to
go there and i think i've only been
there like once or twice
i was more worried about like dude
there's gonna be some psychopath here
with like a machete who's like a creepy
occultist waiting for some young dumb
teenagers there's a lot of famous
stories about it though
where like some photographer for the
local newspaper took a picture and when
they got the the negative uh um when
they
you know trans like published the photo
or whatever it's called there was a
woman sitting on a tombstone in the
photo and the phone the photo you can
look it up it's a very famous photo oh
wow dude there's there's so much awesome
you like ghost stuff but those two
stories are are in very similar
locations too so yeah i want to go yeah
i love that like sometimes like the the
man who has been abducted
when he moved to this town he's in now
he didn't know it was a hot spot for
ufos it's kind of like new york's
roswell you know and it's
when he went there he he opened the
paper and
here's a clipping that says like uh have
you seen the ufo
it was for the support group that he
would eventually take over wow um but i
think a lot of those places whether or
not something did happen there they
attract the energy of people who want it
to happen and there's like a weird
ghoulish company could you imagine being
an alien and you're like
you know you you got your job your
university assigns you to go research
these 15 psychic humans to understand
how they're saying you're explaining my
life and then and you're flying in your
saucer and then you look down at your
tracking system and you go
hey jim all the little red dots are
coming together
what's going on and they're like makes
our job easier i guess and you're like
yeah all the little people have gone to
the same place and they're like perfect
there you go we'll save gas yeah what do
they have like ley lines have you
studied lines that is what this town is
all about
explain those well i don't know too much
about them but because i i'm just
starting writing about this now but they
believe that there's the ley lines go
across the earth
you know like energy hot spots like
stonehenges one this this town happens
to be another and that's where they
think uh extraterrestrials might
congregate because maybe quartz that
might have something to do with it um
but they believe that if you look at the
map of like places where that see a lot
of ufos they fall on these lay lines and
then you get the bermuda triangle which
and then is like almost on the opposite
side of the earth of the marianas trench
i think which is in the pacific it's
like the two deepest points two of the
deepest points so i think what's
happening is there's less there's less
land between the center of the earth and
the sky in those areas that are deep so
there's more water which is more
conductive to electricity so i think
that's why you get these electrical
weirdnesses in those areas maybe there
was there was a story i was reading
or maybe it was just like some theories
about um
i believe this is true there's areas
where gravity is different on the planet
i don't know due to the shape of the
planet and it's like mostly unnoticeable
by humans but it's measurable i could be
wrong about this
and then i was reading also that more
magnetism is stronger or weaker and
that's obvious because magnetic you know
the poles are stronger in certain areas
so that creates effects that humans
understand because it's so massive yeah
that they make assumptions about
everything being the same and you know i
i think a better example would be like
altitude you know people don't
understand altitude when if you if you
are from a coastal city and then you go
to denver you're going to be vomiting oh
yeah try and dance go out dancing in
denver if you've never been up there but
so think about how that what that means
if you're like on the equator
and how gravity might be different or if
you're near the poles and magnetism
might be different technically you're
spinning faster at the equator it's
moving quicker because you know it's
further away from the center yep
um
no
you're making me think like uh
people need to turn their attention more
to underwater stuff oh yeah yeah the
reverse of altitude that's where that
you see all those temples underwater off
indonesia that flood nailed and if you
look at google maps and you zoom out or
any map program you see like the light
blue around the around a lot of the land
mass that's where those used to be above
water before the fl before before the
water levels rose i think it was at the
last 13 000 year old flood and one of
our stories uh that's coming out soon i
was just sorry real quick uh on top of a
mountain in new york uh one of my the
sources of the story used to pick sea
sea shells up you know huge flood yeah
yeah gravity gravity is absolutely i
googled it absolutely uneven on earth
and they say mount nevado huascaran in
peru has the lowest gravitational
acceleration at
9.7639 meters per second squared while
the highest is the surface of the arctic
ocean at
9.8337 meters squared navado nevado was
a bit surprising because it's about a
thousand kilometers south of the equator
so yeah there are areas where you
probably won't notice but i was i was i
was reading something about when they
were when they were doing experiments on
like with like gyroscopes and atoms and
things like that notice serious
differences and how the results are
based on the different gravity wonder if
they looked at people's like bone
density if it's changed if it's better
in one place with less gravity i would
imagine it's got to be right they told
me there was a gravitational constant
growing up nine point eight six meters
per second nine point eight meters per
second squared well they say it's uneven
now apparently
yeah i think uh the large hadron
collider has a problem made a problem
with gravity in this planet did you
follow that story back on no uh i'll
probably write about this at one point
but um there was a lawsuit by some
scientists to stop the large hadron
collider the super collider
i remember switzerland
because they believed the black holes
would uh fall to the earth and cause a
sphere of strangeness that's what they
called it um no one no one argued that
there wasn't going to be black hole
black holes falling to the center of
earth they just said they're not going
to swallow the earth yeah the the well
the singularities exist for so such
short amount of time right that they're
like it's pointless it's not gonna be a
problem but they were the lawsuit was
like they're going to a mass
and and maybe not swallow earth but uh
turn us into this fear of strangeness so
what does that mean what is it the fear
of strangeness strangeness is like they
said it would turn us into like um
almost like str wavy strings
of like cosmic soup what and that
sometimes i'm like maybe that's that's
what happened
that's what our digital avatars are yeah
radio we're in the stringy cosmic soup
but we're online looking like nice like
this when it comes to ghosts i i grew up
um next to a graveyard and in my
backyard there was a fence and then you
crawl under it in the grave and you're
in the graveyard so we would stand on
top of our clubhouse and look at the
graveyard i used to lay in the graveyard
hung out there and i never got any
weirdness if it was the chillest most i
was also had no magic power i was not i
was not they were vibrating probably i
was vibrating the whole time and i
didn't know it i didn't believe any of
this magic crap until in my 20s would it
be funny if that out of all of the
people who have ever come to the cass
castle the one person who has no psychic
abilities is ian i think that might be
true yeah no the we
changed everything
but then i started i'm really into
science and i started to hear about the
phantom dna stuff and i don't know if
you guys have studied this this is a
little bit of an overlay of what it is
basically they take wild electrons they
put dna the electrons form to the dna
they remove the dna and the electrons
stay as if the dna is still there so if
someone is living on the side of the
road and suddenly struck by a car and
destroyed and now they're no longer
there there might still be energy there
in that shape so you're proving my
sphere of strength it's evidence it's
not proof with phantom dna i got some
hypotheses for you oh boy
ghosts ghosts here's one thought
uh what if time is not linear but more
like a fabric that is in in a way we
can't really grasp understand moves
around
what if let me see if i can i don't want
to use that um well i'll just i'll just
try and use my fingers what if you have
this line of time right and it's like
the past and the future
all of a sudden as you know we can't
perceive it time is wrapping around and
then crosses through it itself really
quickly
so you're standing in a building that's
been around since the 1700s and the
1700s quickly passed through the year
2000 so the building stays the exact
same because it's just time not space
and then all of a sudden for for a blink
of an eye you see a man standing there
semi-transparent wearing old colonial
clothes and he goes
and then you're like what the what's
that did you start telling everybody
and then they say yes this building's
been haunted since it was built why an
old man once said that you know here's a
photo of me like that's the guy i saw
and they're like yes the people who
lived here see ghosts too why he saw you
wearing strange clothes going
i grew up in a really old house i feel
that way i feel like if i because i
we have an episode coming out about this
house but when i saw the shadow ghost
situation i thought it was that type of
situation like we were each other's
ghosts you know right he saw me as the
ghost i saw it as a ghost that might be
you might be onto something because if
this phantom dna thing is legit which it
seems to be that it might not have
anything to do with time you may just be
able to pull this pattern into reality
based on your
behav based on you well so what i'm
saying whatever it is if vibration in
the year 1980 and the year 2000 the
building is almost identical because
it's been there for you know 50 years
and so those 20 years but the only thing
that's different is that at this point
there was two different there was one
person standing at one point and one
person think another point and if they
pass through each other the building
wouldn't change at all everything would
look relatively the same you might see
weird shifting and like style or
something but you'd see this person very
briefly like a shadow person or a ghost
and you're like a person they were
wrangled clothes and they would be like
yeah there was a person who used to live
here look just like that people would be
like whoa but really it's just on aliens
so the aliens are us in the future
interacting with our present selves yeah
and the ghosts are our ancestors
but it's not that it's not their their
their dead
soul or anything it's like it's just
time passing through itself right so
here here's my other um
fun story
i started thinking about this a long
time ago why is it that old buildings
are haunted if we're not going to
operate the assumption that it's
people's spirits trapped in the building
what could it possibly be and so i was
hanging out with my friends i mentioned
playing that to the old republic and
they're stoned off their asses and we're
talking about time and i was like
what if there are interdimensional
beings
you know alex jones says they are but
let's say there's beings that live in
five dimensions we live in four we have
the all the spatial dimensions and then
time but we can't control time
let's say there's a being that lives in
five dimensions it control it controls
all four dimensions including time to
these creatures time is perceived like
space
if that were the case then a long amount
of time would be a large amount of space
to them
so if you look at a building that's from
the 17th built in the 1800s and you know
was was there for 150 years
that's a big big building so these
interdimensional beings are like i would
like to occupy this massive amount of
space i have 150 years to move through
like all of each each moment of time
would be a different bedroom so you have
a one bedroom yeah well how many seconds
exist right and that could be hundreds
of thousands of
spaces for them to occupy the reason you
never see them is because they can see
you and they know what you're looking at
when you're looking at any point of time
they just don't interact with you in
that specific amount of time and because
they move through time as if it was
space there's never a point at which
their history would be static
so you could literally never perceive
them
except at one point
they're like look gianni i found this
really really large building it's 150
years big
but around the last 50 years there's a
whole bunch of people moving around and
occupying it so here's what we'll do
let's go back 20 years bang some pots
and pans and smash some glass and then
there will be no one there for the next
20 years
and so they're clearing out the past
good yeah i think a fifth dimensional
behavior as something that can do
everything at once so like i want to go
left and i want to go right but i have
to pick but a fifth dimensional being
goes in every direction at once
or technically neither
yes it has the ability to go in every
direction it would be like saying you
can go left right forward or backwards
up or down and they can go boppo and
bipo
man i think you'd be lying
like time and space is the same thing
according to einstein space time he
calls it but
it really is the same thing
and then how many dimensions are there
you know m theory crazy stuff what we
think we know i think there's a lot more
out there i think we just keep on
thinking we know what's out there and
something like i was thinking about
frontiers and like uh i was thinking
about puritans in salem and like when
they came here uh they were so afraid of
the woods it was
this like wild evil thing you have to
kind of tame and um
so that was their frontier and it was
populated with like myth and ghosts and
demons
and we've kind of taken over woods now
and now space is our aliens and like we
don't know about it but then we'll
conquer that at some point and then it
won't be so ghoulish and i was like what
are the are the ghouls receding back
into the shadows because there's more
humans now
or or are our minds just our
imaginations run wide well let me ask
you what you think about this i was on
my roof meditating i think there was thc
involved and i was just feeling my
magnetic field around me and meditating
and i dropped my magnetic field and
gazed out into space and i felt the
presence of a wolf man sense me and want
to eat me from
up there and i feel like i revealed
myself to it maybe it's just like i'm a
puritan in the woods with with you know
whatever we call it like superstition or
or maybe i i sensed
i think uh
but maybe the smoking like the dmt can
open up a portal that makes you a little
more sensitive to other dimensions you
know like the machine elves i haven't
met them
but i believe they're there if you've
seen them it's all it's all like your
reality is unfortunately whatever you
make it when it comes to those things
yeah we were talking about um
a short story or comic about ian
accidentally mixing monoatomic gold with
dmt which creates the superstructure
which actually allows him to actually
transport beyond the veil instead of
just seeing it in 2007 i was doing crazy
youtube videos and i started getting i
was connecting with anyone that wanted
to talk to me and people this one guy
called me and talked to me for like two
hours without stopping about monoatomic
gold and dmt and apparently that is the
gateway that the ancient egyptians would
use to see but it's all about the mono
not colloidal gold you need the
monoatomic because that's goes through
the blood-brain barrier
and together
i was talking to someone
uh have you heard of like mystery
schools or mystery colleges i was
talking to someone um
about she had what she said she had
witnessed uh one mystery school where
they opened a portal and they bring
beast through it and she said uh she's
uh beasts like other interdimensional
beasts
or bees
maybe i'm a certain no it was like she
said it was like a big dog type thing
that they just unleash and there's
people unleashing these beasts through
the like a stargate is what i envisioned
they came do they have rings that went
over two fingers and they would go like
this
i should ask no i i thought that i saw
the uh ghostbuster dog
that takes out rick moranis oh yeah what
was that thing
i don't remember that was that in the
second one
yeah oh yeah
yeah when the snake juice came to life
zul's dogs yeah that was good
um so what do you think it's like wolf
wolves started eating mushrooms on
another solar system and then they they
were the ones that gave thumbs and
sentiences
i don't know i think what you saw could
be real because you saw it it's like
when people tell me they see jesus in a
pancake they believe in jesus and they
believe they saw jesus into pancake then
they saw that so also am i one of the
stories i have to tell us about uh this
guy i knew who was like
just like a a crust punk drug addict
and you know when i met him he was a
devout christian who lived in like and
worked in a church and did like you know
community community stuff and like youth
stuff and he was a skater
and he said that one day he was in the
woods and he was like partying and he
was drinking and doing a bunch of drugs
and he went to go take a leak when all
of a sudden he felt and heard this
powerful voice from within him say
why are you doing this you need to stop
and fix your life and he like freaked
out and was like what's happening to me
right now and then that's when he turned
his life around he found jesus he found
god and he became a productive member of
society and um like he's a he was a good
good dude he was like a nice guy he was
responsible he was working hard
and i was like
you know my i'm not religious but i was
like you tell me a story about someone
who's on the wrong path and then they
have this this moment and it makes their
lives better it makes them happier makes
them more responsible makes them a
positive you know individual but that's
a good story
but also i thought about it somewhat
differently i was like
have you ever seen the um have you ever
seen the documentary what the bleep do
we know yeah um that's good
it's weird you should i think it's got a
lot of crackpot stuff in it but they do
some some some things that i think are
helpful for people's perspective he
talks about flatland a universe of only
two dimensions where people can only
move left right up and down they have no
concept
or left right front and back they have
no concept of up or down
we with up and down look down on them
and can see everything
so he says imagine there's a flatlander
living in their home
and you then look down over their home
in a dimension which they can't even
they don't even know exists
and then you speak and you say hello
there little flatlander but your voice
goes right into the middle of their
being and they hear your voice coming
from within them and they're like what
is this are you god and you're like no
i'm in a higher dimension
and then you can look in their house and
say in your closet is a coat and a pair
of shoes in your kitchen i can see and
they're like you see everything you're
omniscient it's like i just experience a
different dimension than you so when
this guy told me that story i was like
dude that's just like the story and what
the bleep do we know about the two
dimensional beings
maybe you as an interdimensional being
maybe angels and demons are
interdimensional beings i think it
depends what your proclivities are right
like my alien abductee friend if he was
maybe leaning a little more religious he
could interpret that as you know being
yeah taken into another realm like
heaven or something right but then i
think of like the prophets in the bible
they all were looked at as crazy people
not all of them some of them were like
dirty crazy they kind of sounded like
schizophrenics yeah but they were
plugged in to what the word of god was
and also you know supposedly the word of
god would carry the shreds so your voice
coming down to someone they could
interpret that like in uh dogma you ever
see dogma oh whoa
said his god
exactly another interesting phenomenon
of flatland is if you put a
three-dimensional object into the
two-dimensional plane of flat land they
only see
a like a a circle they'll only see like
a thin like a they don't see and so it's
like a shot you're seeing a shadow yeah
it's like seeing a cross section when we
see
these light things and so the way they
explain it's very simple if you had a
balloon
and it's you know completely round as it
enters the two-dimensional space what
they'll see is a ring slowly expand and
then slowly shrink yeah like exactly
like an mri yeah
so imagine what that would look like in
a third dimension you would see an
object balloon out and then collapse oh
and that's what happens with infrared
light i one time i woke up from a dream
and my phone was like at eye level and i
saw the infrared light go into the phone
it was real distorting and then i felt
my brain kind of twist but it was like
it was contracting it looked like it was
contracting this is really interesting
in um interstellar
they see the black hole
uh or like the wormhole and he's like
it's a sphere and they're like what's a
hole you know in three-dimensional space
it would be a sphere like that's crazy
for us to even try and think about you
know the perception is what's going to
change once we get access to other
dimensions or going to space human
perception will change in way people
think oh man there's so much crazy stuff
to talk about in this regard like
in star trek for instance the problem
i've always i've always had is and
someone super chatted shouted the saying
that you know in my ghost time theory
i'm forgetting that the solar system
itself is moving so the house is into
the same place and i'm like no i i get
that i get that but you know maybe it's
time in a small pocket but anyway in
star trek for instance
if you're on a planet in a different
part of the you know different solar
system where the planets are moving at
different speeds time dilation would
mean
there could be infinitely different
speeds occurring between earth and those
planets
i shouldn't say infinitely but like
dramatically different
and so that's something they don't
factor in they say oh because of warp
speed time dilation doesn't affect them
yeah but a planet that's moving at you
know x you know kilometers per second
versus earth at y kilometers per second
we'll be experiencing time very
differently and time will pass slower or
more quickly for one of the other
players regarding to what that guy said
about the solar system moving so the
house is in a different area if firstly
the the phantom dna thing might just be
able because what i notice about
electrons they seem to be able to spin
down and disappear and reappear in
another area they like they'll turn into
subatomic power so it's like it's not
that they're moving but it's like that
the vibration is is no longer vibrating
there now it's vibrating here and i
think that it might have to do with with
three dimension it like attaches to the
third dimension doesn't matter where it
is yeah
let's go to super chats and uh we'll
take some questions from the audience uh
if you haven't already smash that like
button thanks for hanging on this friday
night and become a member at timcast.com
and don't forget in the description
below is the youtube channel for the
very new tales from the inverted world
it's gonna be amazing because there's
gonna be books
there's gonna be the podcast there's
gonna be the member hangouts where
people talk about these crazy ideas and
so you'll definitely wanna subscribe to
that and check it out if that's what
you're into let's read harry toe says
please have your animation team make a
fight between joe rogan and jenk pretty
please
if you guys are listening to the show
right now get in get in the the private
chat and just let uh ken know unless
kent you're watching that um
you know take some audio clips from the
young turks and from joe rogan and then
give me off the top ropes chunk ugher at
some point
[Laughter]
all right rebel kgf says west virginia
or new hampshire what do you guys think
i think west virginia west virginia i
like the warmer the more south the
better for me i'm not really into
politics i know it's land locked
but but i'll take i'll take west
virginia but it's a good spot because
it's not too hot not too
make sure it gets cold yeah and way
earlier right like i i need i like it
down here i'm very happy down here but i
think if people are interested in the
free state project obviously new
hampshire yeah that's interesting that's
whether you like snow
jeremy mcdude says to opine on your show
segment on secession we don't need to
secede we just need state governments to
do their jobs and take back power from
the federal government the states know
their people more than elites in dc
yes i agree with the amendment yeah 10th
amendment says if it's not in the
constitution then it defer to the state
exactly but so what they've been doing
is they're like it's not the
constitution let's add it right but what
it should be doing is just deferring the
state all right
icemanheatboy says love you guys you
talk a ton about being healthy if anyone
wants a great personal trainer in the
baltimore area or check uh check out
some good workouts visit male fit life
on youtube keep up the great work you
guys
very comfortable my resting heart rate's
around 55.
oh that's awesome
oh your watch measures it yeah can i
wear it for like 20 seconds and it'll
measure me we have one downstairs you
can just go grab nice yeah
yeah so like doing the show my heart
rate goes up a little bit because
obviously it's like there's some energy
there's some work out here when i record
this is funny when i record my normal
segments and i talk really fast and i'm
all like it tells me i'm working out
yeah it's like workout detected perfect
yeah wow but uh when i'm just like you
know earlier today i was chilling and
eating lunch i'm like averaging around
like 55 which is good i guess right good
good it should be 40 though shouldn't it
no 40s i thought it was like 70 to 11.
what's what's what's like the best the
best okay so if you're super fit and
healthy we were watching a patient one
time and his heart rate kept going into
the 40s and we thought he had a complete
heart block and it turned out he was a
super fit biker dude like all he ever
did was ride his bike and i was like
he's just super healthy wow every pump
of his heart is like incredibly powerful
and he likes to do like boom yes exactly
yeah it's very cool 55 is great you're
fit yeah wow i was i was like i was
stoked on that it's been it's been you
know sitting down i've been skating
almost every day now yeah yeah do you
notice if you eat does it eat better too
yes oh so eating better is way better
right if i eat bad i'll i can feel it
definitely if you drink smoking
yep
all right let's see we got
all right
takuma says yuri besmanov said quote
have you ever heard advertising to tell
you to consume less
not to be a horseshoe theorist but
consumerism can lead to big government
as well
that's a good one
they go hand in hand they never tell you
to go to eat less although i did see a
commercial today on fox news for a
company that's like we used to be known
as a tobacco company now we're a tobacco
harm reduction company no and i'm like
that's weird
reminds me of that scene in iron man
when um
jim cramer's like
uh stark says they're not gonna make
weapons anymore that's a weapons company
that doesn't make weapons and then he
smashes the mug or whatever
yeah
justin bell says i work for one of the
largest grocery distributors on the east
coast we are 300 understaffed five to
six day weeks for over a year so burnt
out oh my gosh and people are quitting
yep because they're like yo i can't do
this
that's a vicious or they're getting
fired yeah yes
all right
shedrick staley says first time super
chat and army veteran do you believe
that anyone except veterans that have
seen war will have the courage to stand
up and pull the trigger when tyrants
come to the streets
um i think antifa would go nuts
i think they'd be doing all sorts of
insane violence and i actually think
veterans and people on the right would
be the more tempered ones less willing
to use violence yeah they have the
training because like standing up and
pulling the trigger is not disciplined
not necessarily discipline if you want
discipline yeah i think the military
ex-military is going to know how to stay
cool under fire know when to use it when
not to use it yeah
all right let's see
frankie two fingers says tim and ian
casually mentioning that star wars
blaster bolts move slower than regular
bullets and then moving on like it's
nothing really didn't number on me the
other day
[Laughter]
perception is everything true though
no we know yeah i think what what is the
has anyone ever measured the speed of a
blaster bowl no we got to do it though
it's probably like 500 feet per second
like it's fast but you can see it you
know what i mean true
yeah not that fast
yeah
james garlic says speaking of gold fun
fact all of the gold in our solar system
are remnants from the iron core of the
supernova predecessor to our star and
solar system also this is why we have an
asteroid belt and the and the kuiper
belt oh cool wow yeah i think that the
sun at some point experienced what's
called a z pinch which is where there's
like a high high velocity or something
of energy build up and then there's a
static discharge and then it just
spewed 28 planetoids out
and then they all started ramming into
each other and jupiter and saturn have
like
they have more heat they're giving off
more heat than they're taking in from
the sun so they're like the leftover
star pieces or something huh it's good
really fascinating yeah it's crazy
dakota dad says dr robert lanza wrote
three books on something he calls
biocentrism which states the universe
and reality exists because of human
consciousness not the other way around
quantum physics for evidence
i've heard a lot of that
and um that'd be really really
interesting because think of this
if the universe
was actually dependent upon human
observation consciousness and perception
that would mean that powerful elites who
knew that and knew it was true could
manipulate perception and control the
universe
it kind of veers into simulation theory
because they talk about observer effect
and how you know the the the computer to
build a simulation would have to be
universe sized to make the observer
effect happen
so
yeah you could like there's that as
above so below metaphor where and i've
seen a theory that we're inside of a
black hole our universe that we know of
is inside of black hole so like the
energy you're feeding in is maybe coming
in to the system but then i'm thinking
it's not necessarily three-dimensional
so it more might be more like it's
appearing around us
like the vacuum is feeding it to us what
we think it is or something
all right matthew fumi says rural
oklahoma in the east central electric
coupe has fiber internet 100 megabits or
one gigabit up or down expand out here
as land is near 3k an acre at the moment
3k an acre i think that's that's
actually way more expensive than west
virginia that sounds high am i crazy
yeah in like central west virginia you
get 100 acres for 100k ah yeah it's like
dirt but i guess the point is they have
they have gigabit yeah yeah there are
some there new hampshire surprisingly i
didn't realize they'd have um you know
uh uh cheap land really do they have
fiber
all right let's see
cable dude says youtube keeps ending
your stream and sending me to fox news
those jerks rude
why we're talking about fun family stuff
here huh we're just chilling it's just
friday
j
liebegot says what is d60 i see on cast
castle people that are cast members of
d60 but can't find any info on it
what is that is no idea no no idea
anyway weird maybe maybe those are jokes
because like when they title someone
they give them joke names or something
it's a nikon camera are we using d60s
no no we're not
stephen heinold says tim me and my wife
decided to quit uh it says quick smoking
i think quick quit smoking and make a
deal we only smoke after
adult relations i feel great and i've
never felt better but my wife is up to
three packs a day should i be worried
plus ian get a haircut
never
no maybe someday
here you go
ready to rumble says fun fact if you
invested a hundred dollars in gold 10
years ago you'd have 95 today
and if you invested a hundred dollars in
bitcoin
uh ten years ago you would have um five
million dollars
yeah put a few hundred into doughnuts
like my towards my last semester of
teaching and i got more from dogecoin
than i did from teaching
from a semester oh my god oh dude here's
one amazing christopher thomas
fellow chicagoan last time my sister
went there bachelor's grove she saw
dudes dressed in robes and native
headdresses they started approaching the
car and her and her friend
and china friend took off wow
yeah never underestimated group people
that are all taking psychedelics
the prick says how about a story about
the inez statue in chicago's graceland
cemetery oh i don't know i think i
vaguely remember hearing about that but
i don't know a lot about it
yeah
good stuff out of chicago going on a
list you're gonna send me there for a
month yeah
ramon i mean dude chicago's loaded with
crazy stuff
they're they're i think they're there
was like
i could be wrong about this but they
like tore down a cemetery for like
expanding an airport or something i
don't know i don't know just a lot yeah
ramon galvez says tim look up on youtube
but jesus stops alien abductions this
topic is known by many alien experts but
they avoid talking about it hello from
aurora hey aurora chicagoland area you
ever hear anything like that no i like
it though yeah like what if people are
like aliens are pulling and then like
literally jesus like you know stops them
and then saves them is that a movie
we're gonna write
i could imagine that a strong belief in
something might blockade you from
perceiving that kind of stuff because i
was very um skeptical when i was a kid
and i never experienced any of it now
i'm more open to it and i and now i am
experiencing it a little bit more i
thought it was interesting when the pope
came out and said he believed in aliens
that's interesting it was an awesome
conversation remember that it was a few
yeah four years ago so here the plan is
there's going to be this show tales from
the inverted world which is true stories
shane's a bit of a skeptic but it's
going to be like that's that's what
makes it great is because you know
you'll come out and say if it's not true
yeah and so you'll often be left with
these real mysteries but then it would
be really fun we talked about doing a
full fictional show it's kind of like
x-files about an investigative reporter
investigating these stories and we like
fictionalize them and bring them to life
but that's down the line yeah that's
when we have like a ten million dollar
but like you say time and space are the
same thing so it's ultimately about if
we have the budget and the people that
are ready to go we could start it i'm
technically doing it right now in the
future this is like your real life yeah
yeah
yeah that would be a cool show like
x-files oh definitely no definitely
super fun reach out for some dmt
sergeant buck says tim time isn't made
out of lines made of circles this is why
clocks are round
oh is that so well it is interesting
in order to track the passage of time we
go around because
it just keeps going right and so the way
we think about time is we actually view
it as cyclical
even though
we act we actually feel time is linear
but we map time in a cyclical way isn't
that crazy seasons everything's
repeating itself yeah and then why
should we assume that time it's the
itself would not repeat itself yeah like
in that futurama episode where the
pressure makes a
time machine that's going to go forward
and they keep going too far in the
future and they're like maybe if we go
far enough in the future we'll discover
uh you know a point in time where humans
have found back backwards time travel
and then they do but bender gets mad and
sends them to the future then they
witness the heat at the heat death of
the universe but then also the universe
explodes again and then he's like time
is cyclical oh and it's funny great show
final six warning says
i've either seen ghosts on 14 separate
occasions between the ages of 4 to 31 or
i've had 14 very brief hyper vivid visu
hallucinations i'd love to know which i
mean we've we had ghost stories in my
house growing up yeah like you know
someone would go downstairs and the
water would be running
just like the faucet downstairs would
just turn on yeah stuff like that i yeah
i grew up in a really old house it's
built in the 1700s and remember like old
magnavox tvs if they were like left on
the input channel they would hum really
really low that would that would happen
all the time but the tv wasn't on and i
always thought that was some type of
ghostly apparatus i get these things
where i hear dripping water and it'd be
like drip drip dip
what do you think that like kid and toy
story would think when like every time
he came to his room the toys removed
like
can we get like a yeah right
you know there's there's so much there's
so much kind of that's right for perry
in that regard
so we should we should do a short where
the kid like is playing with his toys
and he puts him down he leaves and he
comes back and they're moved and he's
just
like you're gonna be like 10 seconds
long that's late
yeah they're moving
his mother takes him and throws him in
the garbage because like the kid's
freaking out won't touch him anymore
yeah
all right michael r says hey tim and
crew not sure if you've seen th x 11 30
38 it's a george lucas film and i
definitely think you're missing this
from your dystopian mashup that we seem
to be headed towards
i think that's the movie he made in
college like for his his uh graduate
thing he had harrison ford in it i think
really i think they worked with harrison
on that
chris quiet says long hair hippie has
taken too many drugs he can't stand
hippies but ian is a good guy so i have
no animosity to him but i want to detox
him i'll give you a little um
a little behind-the-scenes knowledge i
actually haven't taken that many drugs
i've i smoked a lot of weed for like 15
years but i've only taken lsd like 10
times in small doses uh mushrooms six
times in small doses i smoked salvia
four times three times is it true that
it's conspiracy to overthrow the
government if you've taken acid more
than seven times or is that an urban
legend i think wait we've heard that
before no that was the rumor going
around when we were taken as what's the
rumor that it's like considered
conspiracy to overthrow the government
if you've taken it
more than a certain amount of time
and i've conspired of those of those
i've only micro dose i microsoft wasn't
really like full doses yeah but that's
about it and other than that it's just
caffeine you know i don't know so you
admit to being a criminal
tim you got me
all right let's see
chris blank production says hey tim if
you all are going to be having guests on
your paranormal podcast you should look
into huckleberry or jeff from the show
mountain monsters they're based in west
virginia and whether or not the show's
legit it would be fun oh definitely like
one of one of the best things about
being out in west virginia is like all
the cryptids are here basically yeah
yeah that's cool perfect mothman you get
the mothman yeah you're the right place
shane yep you ever see the mothman
prophecies
i have you know i feel like i have but
it might be when i was conspiring you'll
love it yeah so good yeah there's like
i'm gonna spoil a little bit with this
scene where he like it's a phone call
and then he like opens the bible he's
like in a hotel and then he like points
to a line and the voice on the phone
reads the line to him and he's like what
it's crazy yeah
what's the uh research facility off the
coast of i think near lyme connecticut
where it's like uh
apparently they're building chimeras out
there or that's the hypotheses
yes yes yes did i did i suffix prefix
that with conspiracy i don't know you
know it's funny because like you want to
default to say conspiracy theory but
then alex jones is like google it and
you do and you're like well he was right
right there's there's ideas that they
developed lyme disease there as like a
bio is that true though no it's a theory
it's theoretical
i i think it was funny when jones went
on uh crowder he's like i got this for
you when he pulls a folder with all of
the articles already researched because
he knows
and then they do it right they put in
front of the camera for two seconds and
if you want to read it you just pause it
and then they give you the data that's
great or you just google it and read the
actual article but it's funny that alex
is like we're gonna bring a folder with
everything i'm saying because i'm
telling you the truth and you don't want
to believe it
it's so crazy that these stories that he
talks about fall through the cracks for
us yeah like when you mentioned cloned
beef
like yo i've been reading the news
non-stop for years and i never heard
that we were eating cloned beef until he
said and i looked it up and i'm like
he's right wow yeah cloned meat it's
like a weird creepy exception that maybe
we're hearing everything because we
heard
everything that we heard it's too much
happening at once and a certain
narrative took over so like that
narrative would have taken over maybe 20
years ago yeah if they put a baby's
scalp on a mouse right yes oh man
here we go
summer is 19 says hey tim i went to argo
high school and bachelor's grove and
resurrection mary all true love y'all
what
uh the the the uh al capone stuff it's
just like look i'm a kid and people are
like that's where al capone dumped the
bodies and i'm like i never actually
looked into it yeah but i love lakes
like we have a lake by me that's like
that called hessian like and the rumor
is no one knows how deep it is and the
firemen supposedly lowered the the chain
all the way down and and nothing i think
he should go to chicago i'm down
totally down because there's there's a
ton of other stories too there's just
there's just
yo
at the end of the last ice age 13 000
years ago apparently have you been to
the snake mounds in ohio there's a
serpent mound it's an ancient native
burial ground but apparently the
glaciers came all the way up they had
built this serpent the glaciers came all
the way up to the serpent latitudinally
and then they just the glaciers stopped
stopped going they thought that this
serpent had protected them whoa maybe it
has oh
yeah now it's like a protected uh i
don't know if it's a natural a national
park or something the nazca lines are
cool too
dude how did they build their obviously
they were flying if they could build
those they must have had hot air
balloons the nazca lines are gigantic
drawings
from above yeah that's incredible yeah
so they must add hot i mean i think hot
air because the vamana is this ancient
flying machine hot air balloon city that
the the king would fly around on or
something right
i think they like the angels and demons
were on hang gliders what is this humans
actually came from venus in a runaway
greenish effect destroyed
venisian
and so they built a giant escape exodus
vehicle run by the military and they
called it the ark project where they
loaded the genetic materials of two of
all the animals they could muster and
then transported after the greenhouse
caused ice caps to melt and there was a
great flood that wiped out the planet
and then they came to earth and
terraformed it and oh man i used to
think that was like fully fully weird
but now
it might have been life on venus but
they didn't have it doesn't have a moon
though right did it ever have a moon
i don't know like for title i was just
one day watching some national
geographic thing or something and they
were like venus has a runaway greenhouse
effect and i was like whoa and then i
just made everything else up oh i mean
it's a cool story though possible like
there's a civilization runaway greatest
effect causes the water levels to rise a
great flood so the the planets dying is
acid rain
ecological collapse so the military of a
powerful government creates a gigantic
project to take as many people as
possible to the neighboring planet which
could sustain life the sun's expanding
so it used to be venus was in the
goldilocks zone and then the sun got too
big we need to escape it's going to cook
the planet and so they take the genetic
materials for the males and the females
of as many species as possible and then
they come to earth in the giant ark
spaceship and then the people come down
made by tesla
and then what happens is you know they
don't have enough technology to maintain
the vessel for long enough so they
evacuate to earth and then the first
generation retains as much knowledge as
possible
we are smart we know a lot you know how
to make fire you can probably figure out
some really basic and rudimentary things
and you know certain things are possible
but you don't know how to make them you
know radio waves are possible do you
know how to get the metal to make
electricity in a radio wave so what
happens after the first generation the
kids have never seen it before and
they're just told these stories of magic
and then by the third and fourth
generation the first generation of
survivors from the ark project are long
gone and all they have is a book telling
them the basic rules of how to survive
don't eat pork
sounds dirty right yeah dirty animals
man yeah i don't have it shellfish yeah
you get sick yeah i do eat those yup
all right let's see
i like oysters yeah i do too like
drinking that oyster thing i'm
pescatarian but i don't like saying
because it sounds like you worship fish
oh yeah do you
i guess i do
josh oh my god josh oh my gosh that's
tim i got i i got an error message it
says arrow 404 freedom not found we just
need to reboot america state separate
and rejoin okay
cool jack attack says i think the most
terrifying thing about humans is that
they have the ability to conquer the
fourth dimension if given time given
that we survive our own great filter
which i do believe social media has the
potential potentiality of being yeah
that a video can be online forever at
any time you can watch any point in
history that's time travel yeah you know
like i can see concerts from before i
was born yeah i like that
yeah it's nice technically not there but
but experiencing yeah yeah but you
you've uh figuratively are there yeah i
can hear the audience yeah you know i
just can't smell it yeah dan daniel
bungie says i'm a retail pharmacist
which means most people come to me to
receive vaccines and vaccine advice i
wish i could talk to you about the
tearful conversations i've had with
people who don't want the vaccine but
their job requires it or be fired
what would you do
what if i was like get vaccinated you're
fired i would leave yeah yeah i'm i'm
not being told what to do you know if i
were still teaching they would uh
they would have made me get it i pulled
up this story called jacobson versus
massachusetts 1905 guy didn't want to
get the uh smallpox vaccine due to
religious things and the government put
to the supreme court supreme court was
like no sometimes you don't have it's a
very interesting court but
in this circumstance the mandates are
like if you want to work
right but what was that circumstance
where they was like was he was he going
into a field of children or was his
religious freedom no but like what did
they hold him down and vaccinate him i
didn't get that far i don't know how
they did it to him how they did it to
him a lot of friends who say like when i
say i don't want it they take it as an
anti you know i'm an auntie that but um
i'm pro them doing whatever they want i
just want to be told to do right
matthew vance says ian i'll sell you a
fitbit but i'm only accepting opals as
payment at the moment hey well that
works out perfectly actually because i
just got a bunch
hit me up it's gonna be really funny
when like in a year opals are worth like
a hundred times their value and like the
like opal becomes global currencies yeah
there's two opals in particular that are
mind-blowing from the images that i saw
so super excited that's amazing opals
are awesome yeah
gc geek army says woody dies in toy
story then the other toys have to watch
in horror as the boy plays with the
corpse in the scene i heard that
that's horrible
that's a horror story right there geez
and they're just like
that's dark stuff
is that what god is doing is playing
with the corpses of people and that's
what we think are like zombies and
skeletons and all that maybe i think i
don't think they're real by the way but
interesting
oh here we go is god playing with our
bodies right now prc e5 says at the
beginning you mentioned fireballs in the
sky last night i was at a truck stop in
savannah georgia and saw an orange
fireball flying horizontally for about
10 seconds before disappearing long
enough to get a picture
meteor
breaking up in the atmosphere i
typically think so yeah i think there's
a cool lot that happened that go
unreported just people see him i was
walking to take the trash out in two
weeks of time i saw three oh nice if you
get so a forest cooper's here from
recoil magazine and he brought night
vision wow and you put those on and look
up and you'll see shooting stars
non-stop i'm just like i'll wish for
this so i'll wish for that i'll take
money
all i saw was like i wish i could
somehow get access to someone else's
opals
as soon as i did it was like i spot a
bunch of opens and i was like yes
come here gave me your blood oh you're
gonna love the opals
i think i want to buy more right now
actually
[Laughter]
the age the age of stupid says i am a
civilian engineer for the us navy i just
handed in my resignation letter because
of the dictator and chief's mandate
moving family to north carolina it's
always new hampshire yep i heard people
are are not getting unemployment if they
lose their job well in new york it was
uh medical workers okay who refuse will
not get on oh
that's so good it's torture dude that's
wicked
so they're basically saying you quit
there there was this viral video where a
nurse shows up for work and they're like
what are you doing here and she goes
nobody fired me and they were like you
have to leave and she goes i'm not
quitting and nobody fired me are you
firing me and they were like leave and
they're like tell me you're firing me
and i'll go
it's because if they do they say oh i
was fired right but no they're making it
like you are choosing to quit
one of the nurses in our delivery room
when my wife gave birth to our daughter
told us that earlier that summer during
kovid
her hospital knew she had it and they
had her work still through like
i wonder what she's doing now
miss mal 92 says tim the premise you
explained is already a movie quote cam
really there's a movie called cam
look it up i'd love to watch it i love
that idea we definitely want to check it
out
chris quiet says vamatima i would love
to hang out with ian for a day
hell yeah yeah we'll just do it we'll do
an auction on the site where it's like
hang out with ian for one day yeah the
highest better let's do it i will never
look at how much money that made by the
way
well i'll just we'll just give it to you
let's just chill we should we'll do a
live event we can talk about drugs or
something it's gonna be fun yeah i don't
know like chemicals chemicals is what i
meant to say well we definitely are
gonna do live events for tales from the
inverted world yeah like live readings
with performance sounds carter making
some music alex doing some
[Music]
i was audio last night like thinking
about being on stage talking to a bunch
of people and like doesn't have to be a
stage we just walk out and talk about it
why don't we do it for halloween yeah
i'm there let's do it 100 100 people
start working with uh with carter yeah
sort out carter is our uh in-house
producer oh yeah a genius by the way
yeah really amazing stuff carter you
rock um ladies and gentlemen thanks for
hanging out on this spooky weird and
wild show on friday in the description
below is the link to tales from the
inverted world youtube or you can just
search for it subscribe more episodes to
come we're aiming for like one a week
but we'll see how it how it plays out
it's just it's going to come as as it
goes and then we're going to have the
hangout sessions at timcast.com where
you can watch an episode you can listen
to it it's not watched and there's cool
sound effects and the is being told by
shane and then perhaps people have more
questions perhaps there is parts of the
story they want to dive in in depth on
and google some stuff and so that'll be
like a longer form conversation which is
more like this but weird and wild and
that'll be at timkes.com so sign up
there don't forget to check out
youtube.com cast castle the other show
we started doing because we are ramping
up like crazy the green room is next and
then there's a cooking show and then
there's a board game and dungeon the
dragons show we're working on a whole
bunch of stuff and we want to do sitcoms
and skits too because
it's about building culture so that your
values comes out in non-political ways
so don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel smash the like
button you can follow me at tim cast you
can follow the show at tim cast irl
would you like to shout anything out
shane uh yeah i'll do a few things uh
i'm a co-host of ready slow with uh sean
strong it's a podcast once a week you
can catch us talking a lot of smack um
my second book is about to come out a
good day yeah it's called a good day for
vultures it's coming out on my own press
vulture house press
and of course tales from the inverted
world um it's going to be the best and
tips if you guys have tips or stories
i've been getting some and i'm tracking
them down i read all the things so you
can send them to shane timcast.com i'll
read them because i'll go good stuff if
if if he checks out shane cash yeah they
might get a comment
like someone someone emailed us about
confederate gold and i was like bro and
we're going yeah later i think we'll do
that this month actually yeah yeah
thanks for coming everyone this is again
like i said uh fluorite this is calcium
fluoride in a crystallized form i'm ian
crossland see you next time i'm very
disappointed that is not a very large
opal ian hopefully we have one on the
table when we're in the studio next time
that would be awesome thank you guys for
joining us for the first night of spooky
season i enjoy october and i'm really
looking forward to all the fun stuff we
might get up to with this new show i am
sarah patrick you can follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids thanks for
hanging out everybody don't forget to
check out the cast castle on youtube and
tales from the inverted world and we'll
see you all next time
you